blood orange apple
white grape mint honey green tea cane
sugar
ginger kombucha are these drag queen
names or what are you reading
the ingredients june china our best
friend for life
okay are we ready are we right
i'm ready really yeah bend it's back
with aplomb
you are more playful than ever i also we
are shooting this late at
night you really come out of your shell
i
love the night you really do that's when
we were kind of no but you really come
alive
yeah we sleep all day and then we work
at night who's we
comics what are you talking about also
vampires do you think that you became
a person that comes alive at night
because you were a comic
or you became a comic because you become
alive let me tell you something
you know i don't like nature sun's out
i'm not
it's hot there's bugs smells like grass
in the summer
i love this remember demeter made that
that fragrance that smelled like grass i
loved it
so did gap on gap grass gap used to make
fragrance but that's how a
grass really smells like that's like
only really really hot girls can afford
to smell like that
that's like make-believe great magical
grass
real grass smells like onions it smells
like
dirt yeah it's gross fresh cut grass
maybe i just have a positive association
with it because those were more innocent
times when i smelled fresh cut grass i
you know when i was a kid it harkens
back to
smells like work yeah that too
all i think is who mowed that lawn not
me it was me
not doing it anymore but whoever did it
is is bummed and underpaid
yeah they're hot they're sweaty itchy
they probably killed a couple
grasshoppers and feel awful about it
i don't like them either you know that
when you i i the first time i ever
wrote a john deere tractor to mow a lawn
in virginia
you mean bush hog no it's a john deere
tractor
you mow to the tractor no you drive it
around and it mows the grass
this is a real item oh my gosh i'm
googling this right now you're gonna
lawnmower but it's like a little golf
cart
you had a fancy ass lawnmower huh i mean
it was like what are these
john d that's what we have look it's 23
so it's a lawn mower
not a tractor look how cheap it is it's
this is me shopping online going so you
have to buy this it's a toy
yeah this is a toy i would buy this and
be like god amazon's really got these
prices
this right here this is gas lighting if
you buy your kid this you're trying to
trick them into
morning to mow and they get older that's
what every toy is we got easy bake ovens
to trick us into being in the kitchen
that's why why are children toddlers
as as toys given babies
you got to think about being a mom even
though you were born two years ago
i've always found that a little creepy
babies me too okay john deere yeah these
are not cheap but this is something we
would drive around
uh the property and yonder we'd mow
yonder
okay i'm with you when you say lawnmower
when you said you're a tractor i was
like you're bush hogging your yard oh
yeah no that the tractor was for hay
the big one that would cut down big
things of hay bell hay for you and then
the thing that turns hay into the
circles
hey bellar a hay baler and you got to go
out there and pick them up with a little
forklift they really didn't spend a lot
of time on these titles they were very
literal you know with cars they
they call them a sierra a malibu this
one it's
yeah it's a haymaker it's just a
haymaker yeah it's a one-channel
what you think it is is exactly what
it's called chainsaw
i hate words that only exist because
they're
in some you know world that that we're
not privy to
like jargon jargon like on a plane you
only
stow your luggage on a plane you would
never use the word stow anywhere else
i'm just like fascinated by that like
why do we go along with that and how do
we know that's not a word you would ever
use
a ship stow away well i think a lot of
it is probably nautical but i'm i'm
fascinated by
like why aren't i stowing this in the
fridge when i put it in the fridge
yeah or well this might just be a
difference in dialect but like you know
like in london you stand in a queue and
not a line
yes i don't know that's the same thing
that's a thing yes but also confusing
because the queue to me is what is on my
netflix i'm waiting to watch it
i'm fascinated by stuff like that which
i guess is the line as well
get in line get in the queue also but
also over there there's all these i
remember the first time i ever went to
london because my brother was going to
college there
and i went into a department store and i
asked where the pants were and they
brought me to the lingerie section
because
underwear is pants and then like what do
you call pain
underwear knickers or whatever it was
but i was just like so fascinated by how
different places called different things
things like i'm obsessed with these
businesses if you sell underwear
globally now what do you call it on the
website this might be an
old school term for written from british
slang but it isn't like the used to be
british
like can you do this can you please do
this in essex uh
you know like whenever they be talking
bad about the the guys and they call
them poofs
gary glitter that's a slang pejorative
term again
that is a glamorous
hate word if that is the hates between
that
and gary glitter was a english former
glam rock star
and i guess wore these extreme
glam glitter suits makeup platform boots
uh it's unclear whether this person did
anything wrong
but no he did a lot of things he did a
lot of things very wrong okay
so it's interesting because there's this
related to what i said yes because
in england like i have found there's a
lot of like because they call cigarettes
faggot i'm gonna get in trouble but like
a lot of people
uh use like term like oh he's a pedo
he's a pedo like
remember when elon musk did that to that
diver peter peter and i'm like we don't
just throw
that around in america but they've had
so many famous people
i guess in their zeitgeist that they
grew up with
have that's very they were ended up
being pedophiles so it's like
i think pita bread it's like a it's like
a trauma in their psyche
that we haven't really had in our
childhoods like mr rogers were never
revealed to be a pedophile later this
person that we
cared about so much all of a sudden like
this other he's a poof
that's what i heard on wikipedia i've
dated a couple english guys they
explained this to me i wasn't really
listening very well because i wasn't
that interested but
there is there's a reasoning there
somewhere
we're going to share this video
so in the 30 of people in green
they are very hungry for milk
so david sinclair is on the podcast and
we're going to catch up first
uh with uh my past week in
arizona and visiting my lover's
family and doing 10 shows in phoenix and
in tempe
and then we're going to catch up with
benton's street it's interestingly true
lovers from arizona that explains why he
why he rock climbs because he literally
had to get to school
he had no choice but to literally rock
climb everywhere he went there is
something very specific
about people from arizona because
it's fascinating to me because david
sinclair was on the show talking about
intentionally stressing your body out
just as a way to stay younger and have
longevity
me in a starbucks line because i look at
people from arizona and and
a queue i look at people from arizona
and i'm like why do you guys look so
young you're in the
sun all the time are you supposed to
look older are you supposed to look
weathered aren't you supposed to be like
wrinkled
but the amount of heat that they are
subjected to at such a young age
probably helps them release those heat
shock proteins
which actually is healthy for them so
this
inhabitable climate is probably actually
creating
bodily stress that makes them healthier
that's complex
yeah i'm a meteorologist now and that's
you can
that's that's so if you if you didn't
follow they're microwaving themselves
to youth and there's less stress there
because you can't
rush it's just too hot i found myself
being like
this climate is forcing me to be less
stressed out
it's forcing me to chill it's forcing me
to just sit here and do nothing
and just be with my thoughts like
there's something about there's a reason
why all the animals and plants here
don't move but you just surrender you
surrender to it
something else that i think is funny is
that um
saying you're from phoenix like
everyone's very ashamed of it i guess
there's like some stigma on like
phoenix sucks and i was like oh the way
around that you guys is just say you're
phoenician
that sounds so much more glamorous i say
you are a phoenix i'm like
i'm phoenician you're from phoenix what
are we doing i'm rising from the ashes
there's also these little pigs that run
around in arizona
what are they called javelina
they are so cute apparently there are
horrible
uh menace uh out there they destroy
plants they are
you know look me they're little bullies
but they're so cute to me and i was like
can i have one and i spent a lot of time
googling if you can domesticate
javelinas
look how cute they are they're like
little pigs but they have on little fur
you can't trust them no but there's
anyone anyone that's wearing a fur cult
in the desert
absolutely not but look how cute they
are they're like they
don't really have necks don't take that
off come on they're oh yeah no sorry
there's hunting look how cute they are
they're wearing little high heels and
like
they're the tiniest feet in the largest
bodies they're like punk rock pigs like
they have little mohawks and they just i
don't know i just
anarchy in the desert they're like
little cherubs look how cherubic they
are and sweet and bulbous and like look
at the back legs they're very dainty and
also pigs
okay it feels like you've moved on
talking about me sorry
but my major stress when i was in
arizona was i have not
had dinner with parents of a boyfriend
or lover in a while i was a little rusty
or anyone because we were in a pandemic
and by the way we were
i was doing the merch shoot of our new
merch launch in arizona so i only packed
our merch and i was like okay my only
options here are to wear like sweatpants
to dinner or like our merch and what
kind of narcissist am i gonna seem like
to these parents if i wear my face on a
t-shirt
to dinner let them know early meeting
who's in charge meeting them for the
first time so i was like okay
i'm gonna go to a mall and i'm gonna buy
something appropriate to wear
to meet my boyfriend's parents
everything i have is passive-aggressive
and sloppy and
they're gonna think i'm like a closet
lesbian if i wear the stuff i wear on
stage like let me just
play the game and dress in a nice outfit
for this dinner
i go to i guess nordstrom when i love a
nordstrom when i love a nordstrom
honestly nordstrom is like to me it's
always
i've always nailed it in nordstrom i
kill it in nordstrom in nordstrom you
can buy two size shoes and they don't
charge you for two
if you have a size because my mom has a
size 10 foot and a size nine
you can buy a ten and a nine i fuck with
nordstrom for that reason and you can
return anything without a receipt
yup you can return anything that said
north shore welcome nordstrom for
letting everybody know
i the only dress i could find that was
appropriate for dinner
with adults was a long-sleeved dress
that went down to the knee everything
was like a
spaghetti strap baby doll like i'm going
to coachella
and like i just got this new molly and
i'm micro dosing ayahuasca
and i sort of i live in topanga and i
think you want to show up
as an adult woman yes i'm 38 years old
dating their younger son
that's the problem is that i'm 38 he's
30.
i can't try to look younger i'm just
going to embrace that i'm a full
functioning adult you also can't show
too hot because then they're like oh
this
this is what what's this what's this
cougar town
i just want to i just want to wear
something that nobody thinks about
no draw no attention not so any of your
clothes not make anyone feel
uncomfortable like i just wanted like
a normal dress that's long sleeve black
to the knee nordstrom's going to have it
right you want to be a backstage worker
black turtleneck black
yes i want to look like you want to move
puppets a hostess at a sushi restaurant
like i just want to blend in
and not look too feminine too masculine
too sexy to not sexy i just want to like
make my body go away by wearing
something neutral
and simple and classic right what
happened to classic classics dead
i looked around this place for 45
minutes
all i could find were spaghetti straps
satin things that you could not wear a
bra with
i don't know if girls just don't wear
bras anymore that's a fun fact i think
they're over it and here's what i'll say
though
there's a lot more female designers now
are female designers
so burned by wearing bras they're like i
want to make clothes where you don't
have to wear
everywhere a bra we're free now free the
nipple i still have to
run a business i have to wear a bra when
i go meet my boyfriend's parents
my boobs are fake and i can't feel them
sometimes you've had your nipples cut
and moved one time sometimes one nibble
get hard the other one won't it's
distracting for everyone it's like my
teeth
you gotta thump it for a couple hours so
you match you're like damn it
you're embarrassing me in front of his
secretly put the ice water on one nipple
i can't see them or feel them it just
looks like my sternum is winking at you
so i have to wear a bra i cannot find
one thing that requires a bra
which is so wild to me and we'll get
into what my other options were but the
most
demure simple dress i could find this is
me
in the dressing room this is a
diaphanous uh
gauze dress to if you want to look like
a sexy slutty mummy
right i didn't know it was completely
see-through
what if i sweat or what if i have an
accident what if a woman that buys this
has a fistula and she
still lets out a little pee every now
and then when she laughs what if i am
spotting one night then it's tie-dye
i you know i i love a good old toxic
femininity slutty moment i live for that
but maybe maybe
maybe you shouldn't do it with your
boyfriend's dad but what is this why do
i unless it's revenge
what but what's this who's gonna wear
this i'm not the ghost in the shell
like what occasion would a woman wear
this to besides
if you're auditioning for any sean bravo
but no you can't have your nipples out
you can't have your your you've never
seen bravo
you can't even see that you can't even
wear underwear with this
we wear skins now i can't wear bra or an
underwear you can't wear skins under
this this is
it's kind of let's just say it is skim
just wearing it two layers of
see-through fabric
look at this you can see it's so
see-through you can see
my belly button hole and where my belly
button
stops and starts it looks like the
garment they put like
on jlo or like shakira under the actual
clothes they wear to be a nude illusion
this is for sale who give me one
one event someone's going to wear this
too especially in phoenix
is this this oh my god there's thumb
holes for your thumbs in the sleeves
[Music]
these are what this is like it's like
you're wearing gauze it's like a giant
ace bandage
oh it's lily a band-aid why would they
sell this who's buying it
is someone buying it am i just not cool
anymore is this what just people wear
i think people are wearing this i bet
we're gonna we're gonna play this and
people are gonna be like you look great
i understand why you think that that's
what i thought one was on the rack when
it was on me
i felt ashamed of myself i felt
dirty and and you look like a foreskin
it looks like you look like foreskin you
look like
a like a wrinkle right here in this one
it's still like an uncirculated you're a
little wrinkled dig
also my tits are not that big it's
making them
those are balls it's it's making them
look unnecessarily
bulbous and large look you can see the
seam on the side
i just can't look how it makes your it's
so see-through
that you can see cellulite dents in my
butt
and then you my butt looks square you
know when something's so tight that even
if your butt's kinda round it looks
square just because the way the fabric
is falling because it's so
thin yeah spongebob i know flatters i
mean beyonce is the only person that
could wear this
oh this is oh very video girl dress it
is very much like
but yeah people are buying this just to
go to dinner and stuff and in phoenix
where
you know they're always spraying maybe
this is camouflage in phoenix it looks
like sand
maybe this is actually how women hunt in
phoenix
cougars hunt for young men those aren't
armadillos those are women in this dress
rolled up
that was my only option then i was like
okay i'm not gonna be a two-bit floozy
nordstrom you're not gonna force me with
these trends
and these um frankly psychologically
abusive
garments that cover nothing defeat the
whole purpose of wearing a garment at
all
right you're not hosting the mtv video
yeah i don't know what i don't know
in what world that's going to work for
anyone to not allow me to wear underwear
or a bra
you pervert you sicko there's britney
spears in the top
video some of us
spot some of us have discharged some of
us pee a little like what if i like i
don't like any
what if let's get a rorschach test when
you stand down vagina to wear that
because if you're not gonna
this is this is it'll cling to your
peach fuzz
peach fuzz i mean if you have black
pubes that's gonna show right through
there
you like a little brillo pad yeah i
don't i cannot so you have to shave your
pussy to wear this dress that's how high
maintenance
this this is also a man made this dress
this i ca
i can whoever made this dress if i put
me in a cage
if you noticed fucking made this it's
real fitted to about here and then it's
like whatever
yeah it's and the goal it's also
probably like 700 you have to pay 700
for something that's barely a fucking
fabric that's nude and we can hike it up
so perfect it is so
it was infuriating to me because i was
like okay i have no option
to not be a humor or i don't want to be
a thot right now
and i don't have the option to be an
adult person if i want to wear this when
i'm single and getting revenge on my ex
or do it for a photo great
but that's when you worry about his dad
but this is my thing this is my thing
about
uh like a couple years ago i went
bathing suit shopping and there were
only bikinis there were no one pieces
and i was like so i don't have the
option to wear one piece even if i want
to i think you made a good decision not
to buy that because if you would have
left that dinner
you would have been your lover's stepmom
and you would have been like welcome to
christmas
boy then i go from the christmas
boy so pivoting slightly to something
that i didn't want to bring up right
away because it might make people a
little bit queasy
or give them an erection i don't know
but i did discover something
on my body that i feel like i need to
come forward about
i took a video of it because i didn't
want to live through this shame alone
and i didn't want to have a secret
i was secret spread shame doing
something i haven't done in a while
which is shave i i've lasered my whole
body for the most part
and in my 20s not recently and so now
there's like kind of these smithers
hairs that kind of
come out random places and i get
hairs around my ankles like long ones
do you ever like cross your leg in a
meeting and look down at like your ankle
you're like oh my god there's like five
black hairs in my ankle
or like you know when you're like
driving and you look in the rear of your
mirror and all of a sudden you have like
a goatee and you're like ah
i know that always happens to me every
time i look in the mirror i'm like what
is this
i'll get like a giant like black hair
like come out of my chin
it's the one and i have to pluck it
every it's just that one or i'll have
one that comes out of my
wicked witch hair this mole on my face
like you know how sometimes like
you haven't plucked the hair in a mall
for a while you're like no
like listen there comes a time in every
woman's life when she has to go to the
forest and go to build her house of
candy
you need to pluck your mold to put into
the start stealing babies
so i found a hair on my leg okay guys
this is my knee this is my private parts
can't see that
this is a hair a long hair
is that a oh my god
is that a low pube or a high leg hair
either way that's too long
it's too long what do i do
what oh dude
i'm gonna leave that there for the lover
to find
can you see that ignore my stretch marks
can you see that bad boy oh
oh my god we need to do something about
this
i need to i'm calling the police
seriously
hmm it's okay it is perfectly
equidistant from my pubis
and my knee first of all is that a a low
pube or a high
leg hair this is a very sensitive
subject for me as someone who has spent
a lot of money on laser to avoid having
to have conversations about hair
and now you're coming here what would
pubepunzel what is that
what is how your pussy what is this but
i can't i couldn't just pluck it and
move on i have questions do i need to
get my hormones checked do i need to
you know i do not shave my legs because
of the laser is this
what did they did the laser missed a
spot and this is just what my leg hair
would look like if i had never lasered
and i just let it grow
that is your wicked hair pupunzel let
down your
coarse little hair so is that a pube or
is that a leg hair
it's a little pube it is puberty but
it's a little coarse and curly because i
you know
you have to straighten out with your
fingers you have to pull on it this
isn't
like a bungee cord of hair it's easily
an inch long hair on my
inner thigh i haven't by the way i it's
still there because i just didn't want i
want everyone to believe me
and i need to have some uh
someone to relate to me to tell me
what's going on if you have a sketchy
hair somewhere in your body good for you
fans
i'd like you to email a video i put my
video out of a shameful hair
good for you fans at gmail.com don't
show your face
you know i'm saying your name if i don't
uh i can't laser my arm because i have
tattoos on it so i'd have electrolysis
down which i haven't done yet
so if i don't shave this arm all these
women full beards
all the time beautiful they're in a
circus okay the lumberjack on my leg
sometimes i shave him and i feel bad i'm
like poor you yours your chest here he's
just
you have all these female icons tattooed
on
does dolly parton just have a monkey
no she's she's been she was like early
but so those are so you have to laser
off
the tattooed faces on your body where
hair would grow no one else does but i
i just feel like you know hair like hair
pushes all the dead skin up so
your tattoo gets like gray and it
doesn't look as vibrant as i want it to
look so like i want to i
shaved the area or i've had them lasered
beforehand you can't do it after because
it'll
it'll just it thinks it's a darkness
from hair and it blister rips it apart
oh yeah
because it looks like lasers look for
pigment that's what they're looking for
in our hair pigment
wild i think we should talk about the
bees next week
don't you think yeah let's push it to
next the merch is more interesting
i want to talk to you guys like i am so
fascinated by the process of making
merch the fact that you guys are buying
these shirts
and they're still into them oh sorry i
want to know because this hair question
it made me it came up i had a
a thought when i was right thinking
about it do you like hairy man
this is a big this is a this is a a
lifelong you know magazines
it's late and then next month don't
you're not you're not supposed to
what is the i will i would love to get
granular about this actually because
as i get older the less i realize
anything i like is anything that's just
when we say i like alpha man i like tall
men i like that
all that gets thrown out the window when
you work on yourself and realize i have
no fucking idea what i want because all
of the things that i wanted
in my 20s led me to toxic relationship
so it's like
if i want it it's probably a red flag
like anything i'm into
is unhealthy for me so if i like harry
man i should go with the bald dorks like
like what you like and what you're
attracted to
you know what i mean like
i cannot let what i'm into or what i say
i'm into
dictate my choices anymore i want to
have you know oh she's free-for-all
i want to have funnel cake for dinner
every night i can't
so yeah well you you become a carnie you
can
what about hollywood though because that
is in the movies
henry cavill is the only hairy you've
ever seen i like a man
with hair i like uh but i'm not gonna
overlook something like clinical
narcissism or dishonesty because i like
hair that much
i like to see the people that buy
tickets to see me i like to touch them
and squeeze them and
the last special was can i touch it and
then the pandemic
happened and no one could touch anyone
everyone better let me touch them on
this tour
i have to do justice to all the people
that send me these like
gifts and letters and stuff that was so
touching
to me i think it'll be touching if i
have a shirt for every city i go to
it's a dress with the solar system on it
that'd be good for houston because he's
near nasa we're in atlantic city they
dress up
no because i'm actually a cougar now so
this isn't funny i
am 38 and i do need to conceive a child
soon so i'm gonna have to bring some
like
sexy lingerie on the road my lover is a
rock climber
this i think will make him want to touch
me climb these boulders
big boy this is sexy it
feels like an armadillo this will not
make you want to touch me
oh and it's got a hairy butt this is my
vision board
for when i must have been 22
royal oak music theater royal oak
music theater if that doesn't make you
a little emotional that's a little
touching you're a psychopath
i'm gonna touch your heart i'm gonna
touch your brain
and i'm gonna make you laugh so hard
that you gotta
touch your privates to stop from peeing
i'm doing venues that are on my vision
board shut up
okay you know you love on a tour poster
opening your mouth
i do you are the venus flytrap of tour
posters
why can't i just use every poster when i
look at people taking themselves
seriously in comedy posters and like
posing and flashing
money shot i don't know i can't take it
seriously
oh my god and then it might you know why
i'm your girlfriend that was my mouth
the poster was just me going uh i love
you your mouth and your chest were open
yes i worked really hard on that tour
that's the poster coolest
i agree too you know that we had to go
you know that we had to rent an actual
corpse in van nuys and open it up to get
that photo
you don't already have it because we
couldn't do it weird
they don't have those yeah the ones that
are in my fridge or that's a whole
different thing
um and so the like these colors like
like see i want this yellow and pink one
that is um
very 80s you're having a baby
and you're having a baby i just shot
this maternity line at target
i wanted it to be oh yeah like i just
found it a makeup line
you're the you're that you're the head
of facebook on the one to the right on
the one to the right i know i just hit
thumbs up
i liked this idea it was just too like i
looked like a lady who lunched in palm
springs in the silk top
we want you yeah exactly and we want you
in the army and then i wanted a map in
the background to like really convey
that i'm going all over america
do you love this because you like a
sketch almost the way the photos shot
you like you're drawn
okay that that's the nicest thing i've
ever heard but it also looks like the
poster of like a coming-of-age movie
mm-hmm you know where like you're going
to travel the world and that's what it
looks like it looks like i need to drive
across state lines for an abortion gonna
be called like hot wheels
yeah totally these look like road trip
movies uh a little bit but i kind of
wanted i love this one
i wanted something that was sort of
unapologetically like fun and positive
and um and selective there's this thing
now where comedians also have to be wes
anderson with their posters and
understated and simple and cool
and sitting in the shadows holding one
malt what are we doing this is i'm not
i'm not true detective like i'm this
isn't you know like a murder mystery i'm
a comedian i'm here to make you have fun
the colors are going to be fun it's
going to catch your eye when it's on a
billboard like
i don't want to look like a corny cheesy
vegas
ad for the chippendales but i also want
to convey like a sense of fun in these
posters without being but you do
understand where the chippendales
perform
so this is what we did and it's called
touch me this was a little bit this was
a photo
that we took that is my lover's hand you
guys don't get to see my lever very
often that is his hand
on the poster holding my arm he made an
appearance on the poster
couple announcements uh we are going to
be in vegas august 7th
at 10 p.m at the mirage get
your your
um keister i know i was gonna say
you get your clear bra straps out for
your tube dress
we're going to vegas you buy a
prostitute and you head on you go to
aldo and you get those boots you don't
think you'll ever wear again you'll wear
one night only this is that
where are the shoes that make your feet
bleed yeah tonight's the night get that
dr scholl's goo that you put on it and
it magically turns into a band-aid and
you get to have it because the worse you
feel when you get there the better
you'll have the better time vegas
is my one of my favorite places to
perform one time i was performing and i
watched a woman
puke in her hand hold it and sit through
the rest of the show
that was me also i am in reno
with taylor tomlinson this is a a
rare probably the last time you will
ever be able to see
me and taylor tomlinson on the same show
unless it's you know yeah we do we're
co-hosting the oscars or something or
try decide to make a big career blunder
by doing a shitty road trip movie for
the codependent tour
yes but i went with you and taylor on
and it was this is what during the
pandemic when the middle and people
thought
they could do some shows and just for i
mean for the luck of the drop
you could see three or four comics just
in one walk
that's right so this is at reno we are
gonna be in july 23rd we're gonna be the
grand
sierra resort you get two for the price
of one you get to see
taylor uh first and then you can see me
come on which is gonna be taylor in ten
years you get to see then i'll be before
that
i'm on before taylor announcements leave
us a voicemail we'll get to the
voicemails next week because we're
running out of time but your voicemails
we're going to start playing them again
on the show now that we're back up and
functioning
text me for secret photos uh
birthday i send custom birthday
announcements every morning i'm back on
the wagon with that i fell off for a hot
second and i apologize
updates see i send secret photos to this
text chain that i don't put on social
media
they're very embarrassing you'll
probably sell them for a lot of money
eight one eight two three nine
seven five two seven i'm not stealing
your data don't panic i don't care
uh email us at good for you fans at
gmail.com for
send videos send songs ask us for advice
send pictures of your leg hair send
pictures of
the slutty peasant dress that you're
making work disagree with us
tell us what you don't like yeah we
listen to you guys
we're we're still insecure enough to
really listen to fans
um send us stuff like that subscribe to
the youtube channel
you gotta like subscribe to your channel
share it with your friends very much and
don't be mad at me because we're touring
a lot emily
is on the road with me sometimes
sometimes the youtube video for the
podcast is gonna come out a little late
sometimes it's going to come out early
there's times we're on the road
it's free so and by the way if you
subscribe you don't have to worry about
when it's coming in because you'll know
you'll get the bell notification so you
know when it comes out
you gotta hit the bell notification look
at all that you have to do it
yes don't bother making that comment
that no one's gonna see
that's gonna make you feel better for
five seconds and then shame later
and then just hurt my feelings leave a
good comment yeah just hit the bell
instead
leave any comment because we need them
okay we love you guys you want to sign
up don't worry elephant
david sinclair is here get ready to have
your life
irreversibly altered and extended
are we ready here's what i do on this
podcast my goal on this podcast
is to take people that someone
everyone's already a fan of you you made
it you're famous not everybody somebody
sent me a death threat and wanted to
break my legs that's because they
probably knew you and were jealous
and they were like he can regenerate
he's he'll know what to do he didn't
like that i liked women
i said women are the strongest sex and
he said what are you going on about
okay so what is this on instagram
this he emailed me and he said uh i
assume it's a he
he said what was the what was the email
provider i can already tell you what
you're dealing with was it an aol was it
an earth link without even opening it
you can ask
boston police no one is threatening you
from a gmail
i feel like this is from an
earthling.net a hotmail
yeah probably a dm somewhere uh-huh yeah
it was vicious
and do you do you look at all of your
emails i do
i do i used to reply to all of them how
does that not age you isn't that
the first it's really hard right as like
sort of
the foremost authority on anti-aging
don't you feel like that undoes
all of the supplements you take yeah
well it's pretty stressful what i do but
uh then i have to counter it with all
this other science i have to science my
way out of it
sure and then just in terms of becoming
a famous scientist i
because here's what i'll say for anyone
that knows me anyone watching this
podcast this is the most gussied up i've
ever gotten for a podcast i'm
i it's very hard for me to get
starstruck i get star struck by
like super brains that i admire like
yours i have read your book
numerous times uh i remember when your
rogan podcast came out that was like two
years ago it was over like the holidays
and i listened to it over and over again
because i don't have a family and
nowhere to go on the holidays so i spent
it with you
learning how to stay young i've made so
many life decisions
based like you're such a big part of my
life and you know you don't even know it
yeah i want to hear all about it yeah we
are you're a big part of my i'm
stalking you yeah i am like very you
send me an email
i sent you an email i just i wasn't i
was exaggerating i was trying to be
funny when i said i was gonna break your
legs
it was more like i just want you to come
to my house and then i need to handicap
you so you can't leave
it was it was a joke i have to tell the
police it's called saturday not worry
about it yeah
um but so i am fully wearing jockey
pants
i put on like flats with bows on them
to try to impress you i don't know what
my goal even was i'm very impressed i
don't know what i'm doing and
to talk to talk about anti-aging on a
package i dressed like a 75 year old
lady i look older for this podcast for
something i put on like
mad men red lipstick like i don't my my
goals say hey i used
all of your advice and look how young i
look and i dressed old
for some reason just to be like hey you
think your science works why do i look
like this
a total just self-sabotage move on my
part
but you're looking great don't worry
about you oh well okay finally you said
it
was waiting for that is that what you
wanted me to say so you're a world
famous
biologist now you are a professor
of what am i going to say this right
professor of genetics
yep is that correct uh yep numerous labs
around the world one of which is at a
little place called
harvard yeah it you can't get
more esteemed and accomplished than you
i don't know about that but uh i do okay
fine
the most amazing guy and now whatever i
say it's all downhill from here well
look i'm cuz i'm gonna
throw some things at you that you may
not have discussed on podcast before
because
i don't want to repeat stuff that's
already been on joe rogan you guys have
followed
david sinclair i'd say listen to his
rogan again before
pause this go and then come back because
i'm going to build on some of that and i
want to get into your book lifespan
because i have questions i have
i have had this interview in my
imagination
for two years now well let's do it
no pressure i'm going to start with a
couple questions i also want to stop
you're from you're australian i am
i'm obsessed with uh ancestral trauma
and how we inherit it how it imprints on
our genes
if it what we inherit is there anything
specific about
australian ancestral trauma am i allowed
to bring up that convicts used to go
there is there anything
yeah there's a there's a lot of that
guilt that we're all convicts we're all
bad people
and because we didn't come from puritans
it's the opposite if you're
if you're an australian kid especially
males
and you try to do well at school you get
beaten up we call it the tall puppy
syndrome if you stick your head up you
get
cut off so i had to escape that because
i'm way
an overachiever so it's shame about
doing too well
or doing better than anybody else as to
make them feel bad
right so there's a whole bunch of us we
weren't nerds but we were
like we did okay in exams
we wouldn't talk about it we would never
say what grades we actually got
i would use a different vocabulary i
would have to filter
big words so that i didn't sound smart
so then i came here and people went uh
hey it's okay to use your vocabulary
it's okay to do okay in life
right i'll stay here yeah we celebrate
and glamorize being
better than everybody else yeah plus i
try
really hard so it looks like i'm not
trying but i'm swimming really hard
under the water
is there anything to be said about you
know
inheriting whatever criminal whatever
that even
means thinking criminals are very
creative they don't love authority
they go oh you said this is true i'm
gonna do my own
do this on my own i'm gonna do something
that might be a little bit
um ethically on the fence so that i can
get this bigger result you know just the
ability to push through
any kind of social norms or fear of
criticism or judgment or being bad
well australians tend to follow the
rules and i don't like that at all i've
got
what i'm calling the fuck eugene yeah
and it comes through my grandmother
through my father me and our oldest
daughter who's got it in spades
and it's tough raising a teenage person
with the fuck eugene
but basically what we what we say is
authority doesn't know anything and
we're going to challenge it and that's
why i'm a scientist because i like to
disprove
people australians do tend to rebel
because
yeah convicts screw the british it's
kind of the americans australians very
similar
that way except we didn't have religion
over powering everything
fascinating so i just the fact that i'm
seeing you in person
is even more surreal because you do
actually look 22.
and you know how sometimes you go to
like a dentist and their teeth are
crooked and they're like
i don't know about this or like you see
like an out of shape doctor
you're like you walk the walk in a way
that is so compelling
thanks it's been very expensive plastic
surgery
but you can't
so how have you gotten younger in this
past decade we know about the
supplements you're taking i mean
obviously recap
but do you feel younger not only look
younger and what's the difference
is there one uh you can look younger but
not feel younger
but that's not what i'm about it's all
about extending your body's health
and then living longer because of it
because you don't die if you're
unhealthy unless you choose to right
as long as you've got friends and you're
you're healthy and happy even if you're
100 years old you don't want to die
despite what we might think about when
we're 100.
but i feel younger than i ever have i
can't remember feeling this good
um i'm not going to take my shirt off
but i i don't think
i've aged that much since i was in my
mind i've seen you with your shirt off
thumbs up i'm not
supposed to talk about that sorry i was
a photo
it was a photo from asana it was
it was for science so what do you do
to stay young on a daily basis
uh well if there's one thing i would say
has made a big impact it's to eat less
and less often yes so not starvation
we're not talking malnutrition here
but we don't need to eat three meals a
day with snacks in between this old idea
of you shouldn't be hungry and that
stresses the body
that's a bunch of bs right science says
that we evolved to be hungry
part of the time and that turns on our
bodies defenses against disease and
aging
so i've i barely have ever eaten a
breakfast in my life
um i do eat lunches occasionally but try
to avoid them
and then i have a pretty decent dinner
and i think it's a great way to live
and some of the misinformation that
we've gotten is eat
little snacks a day to keep your
metabolism going if you don't eat
enough your metabolism is going to slow
down is that just we've all just been
lied to
yes no really and we've studied this in
my lab and i
have done this too when you restrict
your calories your metabolism actually
speeds up
oh wow yeah there are little battery
packs you've heard of mitochondria
you've read my book you know what they
are
you get more of those when you're hungry
and they speed up
and so i feel more energetic than i ever
have and i actually if i start to eat
again
if i if i had three meals a day i
couldn't think straight i've done it a
few times i had
unfortunately i went out with my son and
i had this
was a chicken fried chicken burger and
for three days i felt sick it got stuck
in my
digestion so i don't want to go back to
that i love
the feeling of just being fit and i
don't feel hungry that's the
misconception people go oh you know
don't
if i miss breakfast or lunch i'm going
to be thinking about food
it's true for the first two weeks right
you have this addiction to put stuff in
your mouth
but once you're over there it is a
scarcity complex for me like growing up
because there's also is there what is
there you know
in terms of discussing like scarcity
complex like if someone wants to achieve
this goal of not eating breakfast and
lunch because it's better for your
longevity like
there are some emotional obstacles to
some of this maybe not for you
necessarily but like i grew up in a
household where i kind of never knew
what i was going to eat next like there
wasn't a lot in the fridge
so in my head if i see food i have to
eat it all and then i have to have more
backup for later because i never know
what i'm going to eat again you know and
that's
you know i think something that's worth
sort of discussing here is like
a lot of the if you want to achieve a
lot of the goals
that your research
has proven to help you live longer there
are also some
emotional obstacles that people are
going to have to do on their own and
some reprogramming from their childhood
and their trauma
yes it might not be easy but you have to
figure out why
you feel the need to self-soothe with
food or cope with food
for sure and i'm not perfect i still go
to the fridge at night and i want a
snack
it takes some willpower to try not to
sometimes i fail
recently developed a twizzler addiction
so that's that's not helpful
the licorice ones they're really i'm
obsessed with licorice yeah
very few people like licorice but it's
poisonous do you know that it's
just last year someone died from a
licorice overdose
are you sure it was a licorice yeah yeah
like over six weeks
this guy was it the root of licorice
that killed him yeah the extract of
licorice there's a poison in there okay
i'm such a
okay so i'm a comedian i'm not a
scientist shocker this might come as
you know a surprise to you but i do not
have a phd in biology but
you know comedians we like to think like
not devil's advocate but we like to sort
of
look at something from every point of
view and we're the annoying people
that are like but what about this and
and i'm gonna be wrong every time is my
guess but this is
how i think like when i think about
supplements right
so you're taking vitamin d i'm saying
this right resveratrol i have it
you might be the first person to ever
pronounce that correctly impressive
yes i have it i have it by thorn that's
the brand i take
okay and then i take everything that you
take why do you look younger than me
um but you know when i think about okay
someone that's on these supplements
is going to be healthier let's say in
five years after taking them
but isn't the kind of person that takes
supplements
already healthier because it's the kind
of person who's probably not drinking
and probably not smoking it is probably
working out how do we
know the effects are from the supplement
and not from the fact that the type of
person that takes supplements is
probably healthier in general
in other areas of their life well there
are two answers one is we we do this on
mice initially
and then on so we know that they're not
yeah right drinking tequila or not yeah
at least as far as i know when i look at
them there's no
alcohol in the cage uh but in in my case
i lead a pretty crappy life i don't do a
ton of exercise
i hate running uh i probably have more
alcohol than
you'd expect um and but still
it's overcome by these other things that
i'm doing
uh but yeah there are plenty of things
that you you could do that are bad for
you
the worst is smoking so yeah i hope
anyone who's listening who smokes
that'll
that'll age you rapidly we can measure
age now and you can see it speeding up
can i ask you a wild question about that
like when i look at people that are
smoking when i look at
the fact that we get really addicted to
sugar we love sugar we want it
it gives us dopamine is is my guess or
endorphins or something
are we hardwired on some level
to like be suicidal because of the way
the things that we're attracted to or
get the most pleasure out of are now so
unhealthy does that mean
that the that we've just evolved to no
longer
need the benefits of those addictions or
those dopamine hits at one point being
addicted to sugar probably served us
very well because we were obsessed with
finding the net but now we have food
aplenty and available
so now that survival mechanism has
backfired
exactly that's the problem with the
modern world is that our brains want to
have enough nutrition
and food so fat sugar tastes good and
that helped because
the reason to exist is to breed uh and
to ensure the people who are related to
you survive
you know it might be your step your
brother's kids whatever
and so we evolved to love calories
love sex put some sleep in there too
but mostly it's we've got these cravings
the problem is that
our bodies didn't care about our bodies
when we're 80.
that's great right and so the only way
to trigger those defenses
is to go without and put your body in a
state of perceived adversity
and so i really have turned my my brain
into
a sugar-avoiding uh organ
if i eat anything sweet it's actually
i'm gonna get in trouble for this but it
would be an artificial sweetener
which i still think is way less
troublesome than actual sugar
but yet sugar spikes are bad for you and
what that does is it tells your body
don't worry times are good don't have to
fight aging you don't have to fight
disease
same with sitting around like we do in
front of computer screens
that feels good we watch movies eat
popcorn but that's the worst you could
do
for long-term survival it's not too bad
if you just want to breed and die early
and um the name of my next book um
and then i'm thinking about what you're
saying and as someone that is
you know whether it's inherited whether
it's genetic whether it's epigenetic
whether it was my conditioning whether
it's my parenting whether it's nature
and nurture whatever it is
you know um or just the hard wiring of
a hyper-vigilant person or being i'm
obsessed with the night watcher theory
of the people that are now insomniacs
because
perhaps you know thousands of years ago
in tribes there were people that stayed
up all night and they read with each
other and kind of some of us
just at midnight are all of a sudden
super awake and have in can sleep during
the day and it's that you know
um is that are we vestiges of that who
knows but
um but everything i'm hearing about
that's healthy
my question is like so if i'm in the
airport
and my options are to not eat forget the
skipping meals this is my one meal it's
dinner
or to eat something unhealthy with a
bunch of sugar is the stress
of not eating worse for me like the
production of cortisol
and the perseverating in the brain and
the self-loathing and the guilt and the
shame
is that worse for me than just eating
the quote-unquote unhealthy thing
well you if you obsess that much maybe
but for a normal person
it's way worse to eat the food
interesting
there was a great experiment um at the
nih they took ten thousand mice and they
gave them different diets
more protein more fat more sugar
and it turned out didn't matter what
they ate it was when they ate
and so the stress of being hungry for
those these mice actually helped them
wow so putting your body under
uh intentional stress to uh
prolong life and health like you talk
extensively about
cold sauna we know all this i remember
listening to the heat shock proteins i
have a sauna i started doing sauna cause
of you
changed my life i'm benjamin button now
but is there anything to be said about
emotional
adversity or emotional stress in terms
of because from what i understand
if you can't get a hold of it that's
something that can shorten your lifespan
and damage your life and perhaps your
dna is there any benefit
to emotional stress and is there
literally a difference
so this term hormesis means what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger or live
longer in this case
so my work is really stressful uh but i
manage it
i used to freak out um but i was
i found myself also getting older i
could see it are you look what happens
to presidents it's not a secret
while but you have to take control it so
excitement a little bit of stress is
good but if you overdo it this is
this is the problem same with anything
if you starve
you die if you run too far your joints
wear out
if you don't sleep you're in trouble but
if you do a little bit of that stuff
enough to make your body
freak out a little bit even emotional
stress can be good for you
but not too much so the other problem
with the word stress is
it means different things emotional
stress is different than biological
stress body stress
not being not having enough food
biological stress that's different than
emotional stress
cortisol you mentioned i think you
mentioned yeah cortisol is really bad
over time
uh your body emits when you're under
duress when you produce adrenaline
basically
and it help it makes you hold fat around
your midsection rate
yes uh that's true
you're impressing me um so i i used to
keep fish
aquarius i think we call them i'm fish i
okay i used to and you could tell the
difference between the fish that was
happy and the one that was picked on
because it the one was picked on would
be not just small but
sick and dark and would die young you
don't want to be that fish
you want to you don't have to be the
dominant jerk in life but you do want to
try and get through life without
worrying
so i give my men i'm a mentor to a lot
of young kids
and i one of the things i tell them is
just
live every day as though it's your last
um
but don't be pessimistic act as though
you've got a million more to come
and focus on the present and what come
will come we're all going to die anyway
right sorry everybody but that's the
truth
right we're not going to live forever
but just enjoy being alive
uh you know i was on lex friedman's
podcast came out just the other day
and he asked me about this and i said
i'm so happy to be alive because
for those of you listening i'm holding
up a coaster i met a this is a stone
coaster yes
the difference between me and this thing
is massive right this thing will never
be alive it's never going to be happy it
will never enjoy life
when i wake up i'm excited that i'm not
this coaster i'm this living thing that
can do things
i know it sounds corny but i really do
live my life like that and the stress
goes away when you realize
how cool it is to just be here but what
blows my mind
is that being neurotic being a
person that worries served us really
well
for thousands of years the most anxious
worried person was probably the one with
the highest probability of living for
the longest time right what's that noise
what's this we shouldn't eat this berry
we ate this very last time and it didn't
go well like what's that in the bushes
like that
probably served us really well and we
did we evolved
to be sort of uh have the
ultimate advantage being that we were
hyper vigilant and worried all the time
and now
all of a sudden because there's less
predators we get to have locks on our
doors
we've got mace we've got police officers
now all of a sudden
that just makes us sick instead of
protects us and helps it does
it does but um what you want to do is be
around people who are stressed out and
let them worry about it because they're
going to die younger than you
and you'll just get the benefit so these
people that are obsessed with success
and worry let them do all the hard work
and then you can just
benefit from them right you can imagine
in in the old days
let's say you're in a village and there
are people who are just stressed out all
the time they're inventing the bow and
arrow and fire and all that
that's great but they weren't the ones
that probably lived the longest the
people who live the longest it's a fact
are those
that have a good sense of humor don't
stress these are people that rarely get
sick
and often drink red wine every day
can i can i can i ask you a question
about that so
you know and i guess we don't know this
in mice and then i have so many
questions to get to but
is there anything to be said for
thinking about something
and i guess there's no way to quantify
this thinking about something and
exacerbating the negative effects by
thinking about it now i have no
scientific data for this
but if i feel a sniffle or feel
something sick going on
if i ignore it it will not get worse
this is what i believe
and if i go i'm sick i don't feel well i
will get sicker and i feel like i like
manifest it you know
i don't know if that's science maybe
it's not as bad as i thought and i
didn't stop it with my
brain power it just went away and i
didn't think about it but
in my head whenever i succumb to being
sick
i get it's like i give my body
permission or something
like is there anything to be said about
about being conscious of all this
but if we think about it too much is
that manifesting the opposite effect
well you can definitely will yourself
into health that it's called the placebo
effect
right i'm gonna cure you i'm gonna lay
my hands on you get better yeah and
often people do it's called a
chiropractor
we have plenty of these charlatans in
hollywood uh yeah he just
offended a million people that's great
is there that's my brand
um are there placebo effects in
genetics oh wow
uh yes there are but it doesn't change
your genome it changes the control
systems the epigenetic
and yeah that's what placebo is doing
it's changing which genes get turned on
and off
so if i just tell you that you're a
superwoman
you think you are and that'll turn on
genes that will help you
like if you smile during exercise you
get stronger and you're less tired
is that true i think so oh i better try
that yes because i'm miserable
yes apparently if you smile it activates
like um endorphins and you have then
more energy
if you listen to an amazing song if you
listen to eye of the tiger you're going
to run faster
you told me you cry when you exercise i
sometimes cry when i exercise when did i
tell you that
how did you did i really admit that
there are times
in when i was in the spin class when
they would turn the lights off
emily's done it with me and they would
play you know like uh the lannis
morrison song and when you're just
working
so hard something would happen where i
would just release
emotion it was pretty embarrassing to
look at but the great thing is you're
sweating so much that people don't know
if it's tears or sweat like it's the
perfect
place to like cry in public and nobody
really knows
good but smile while you're doing it
yeah exactly yeah oh that's it i mean
that's my whole thing smile through
tears that's called being in hollywood
baby um there's a lot i want uh
to get to is are there any updates
on the nad front you're a strong nad
proponent you even give it to your dogs
and i'm gonna start this week
giving it to your dogs yes okay uh
to talk to my brother about that he's
working on that okay yeah
uh so yes there's a there's a lot to
update you on
unfortunately you haven't published it
and i can't tell you oh my gosh
what happened to darkness just hits you
in the night yeah yeah uh so does
everyone know what nad is you want me to
tell you i believe that one
you just recap it and keep going while i
uh clean this up
can i get a towel i just you know what's
so annoying about it
is that i had this and i was like i
cannot drink a coffee with milk and
sugar in it in front of
david sinclair and i did it anyway and i
put it here and i was like who do you
think you are
drinking this right in front of him
saying fu to all
to have lifespan next to this to go this
is my favorite book on the planet and
i'm drinking a milky sugary coffee with
a plum
in front of you and then of course i had
to knock it over it was like the
universe was like we're not gonna let
you do that it's just it's too arrogant
yeah so i just knocked over my sugary
coffee yeah i think you just did that
like his is
it being around you it panics use the
force yeah molecules start to panic that
are sugar molecules they just want to
get away from you
so excuse me i just see this what
happened i wear a nice shirt to try to
impress my hero and then i spill all
over it this is why
mommy can't have nice things i can whip
myself in there more even
you are competitive i am wetter than you
know
you're like oh you're like i will be
dead now
now we're in a wet t-shirt contest but
now you can see this thing under my
shirt oh my god okay plot twist
what's that okay you are a robot i knew
it i am it
i mean i wouldn't be surprised becoming
a cyborg actually lex
program you on his podcast what's
happening
uh this is a little uh can you say
flashing
yes
but thank you so much what is it and can
i have it even if i have fake boobs
uh you could stick it on yourself right
now what does it do it tells me it's
it's a biosensor okay
tell me everything all right so we'll
get back to nad i assume but it's
pouring water on it gonna make it catch
on fire like luggage i don't think it's
supposed to get wet actually oh no
it might electrocute another shirt can
we get him a shirt
a bike a merch preferably the merch can
we get him a shirt because now
his his bio device is wet with this
water
and he's still on it no i swear i didn't
spill on him he's
i spilled on myself and then he's
australian so he's nice and to try to
make me feel less embarrassed he just
doused himself with water
and it probably is infiltrating his bio
tracking device you should never get
them wet i'm in trouble
this is a million dollars well no no
they're not no no okay
but i bought and you sweat in them or
you don't wear them when you're in the
sauna i wrote always
and where is the data that's in it going
uh
i it goes to my phone and then it gets
uploaded to a company that monitors me
to see if i'm sick or not
okay so they can see everything that i'm
doing unfortunately sick as in how what
could it pick up that would indicate
that you're set a heart rate
well because heart rate body temperature
movement sleep vibrations
breathing okay so it'll be glucose level
sugar levels
really yeah so everyone has access to
this i know about the aura ring excuse
me
it's a ring this is this one yes oh is
that the aura ring
yes okay so i had the aura ring but i
got annoyed at charging it
i just couldn't i just couldn't right
you have to remember i wasn't ready it
also goes right on the ring finger i'm
not ready for commitment on any level
especially not a tracking device
i will not get married to something i
have to charge i can't i'm not taking on
any new charger put it on your middle
finger that'd be a problem
isn't there something to be oh it does
fit there isn't there something to be
said
for going okay it would be healthier to
do this but if i do it in a way that's
stressed out and adrenalized and crazed
and frazzled it's gonna undo all the
health benefits of it
if it's a little bit of stress you're
okay okay yeah right but if it's me i'm
like i lost my aura ring
it was causing me so much more stress
than it was curing
the oral ring is not for you my
childhood i need to work on that
you you do you need more than a ring and
also i felt judged i
because i also was not peak this was
after i had cove and i was not
in peak shape and it was like minimal
unimpressive activity like it's a little
judgy the way that it gives you feedback
it's like you don't know if i'm
handicapped that could have been like a
huge deal that i
walked those 22 steps it could have been
a miracle quite frankly i could have
gotten out of a chair
that i was paralyzed in i could have
literally
just executed a miracle and
you went low performance today
right right you could have you could
have been having sex all night
and that judges you you didn't get
enough sleep yes yes it's not fair no i
sleep during sex so that would have been
perfect
okay so i'm putting your aura ring this
is something that tracks your pulse your
temperature i just put on my finger
is it going to ruin all your stats i
feel like your doctor's going to call in
20 minutes and be like you need to
could well
[Music]
okay so if i put that on me right now
and it tracked
my body data your doctor would just
immediately yeah oh my god
you're having a heart attack you've
suddenly become sick
you're diabetic you're full of sugar um
and why are you doused uh
in so many liquids we do have another
shirt for you if you want it do you want
to put this on
you don't switch your yes oh my gosh i'm
totally gonna put on your
what's it called a bio tracker
this one's called a buy button a bio
button okay
rip it off let's go careful be careful
please it's gonna be covered in hair
okay i mean look i'm about to add oh my
god
such a weird it really hurts pink okay
that's right my boobs are numb because
they're fake so i won't feel it oh it
looks like those tiles remember
you know the tiles that helps you find
your phone and stuff this is like a tile
for a human there is a little bit of
blood on it did you
there is did you just rip that do you
see any i hope i hope you're okay over
there okay
um okay i'm gonna is it sticky stick it
near your heart it should be sticky
okay the heart's in the middle right
usually
it depends how many hearts do you have
you know so you know when you're a kid
you like do the national anthem and
stuff and you think your heart's like
here it's more like heat it's pretty
central a bit to the left
okay if you're an octopus i think you
have three uh don't you have one for
each leg if you're an octopus
or a brain for each leg it's a brain
yeah should i just come teach at harvard
i feel like i'm ready
yeah sure you can come teach instead of
me okay hold on no mine's not sticking i
think it's because i'm also so oily i i
lube myself up in grape seed oil every
day so i don't know if it's going to
stay on i'd have to hold it
okay i'm holding it is it okay that i
have a giant bag of silicone in between
this and my heart is that gonna be a
problem
try to go to the middle is this gonna
bake my boobs yeah what if my boobs just
pop because of the
they go hit the button the bluetooth and
it'll sync and you'll get a green light
okay okay does everyone sit there we go
oh my god i feel like e.t
e.t phone oh my heart light's on all
right
my phone's gonna ring off the hook now
oh my gosh okay so i'm connected to your
device
they're gonna think that you've got
kidnapped and
have been forced to ride a roller
coaster for
like 17 times in a row it'll send me an
alert that's for sure because things
have suddenly changed
they're just writing your obituary now
wait so
get to the hospital right i can't even
just stick on my skin
is that a problem uh you can get extra
stickers
do you wanna i can get an extra sticker
for you you wear this all day every day
yep okay and you see the data yeah
and how do you feel when you see the
data does it inspire you to change your
choices or it's just an affirmation of
yeah i did
nailed it i was right uh
it's a bit of both it's more just make
sure that i'm i'm not gonna have a heart
attack next week
because um sebastian younger on um on
joe's podcast
he was he almost died and he said what
can we do we're gonna die tomorrow we'll
never know
that's not true you will know that thing
will tell you if you're gonna die
and you'll get to the hospital before
you have a heart attack does anything
like this
i'm just this is a a question that
probably can't be answered and it's
probably just like an interesting weird
masturbatory discussion
but is there anything to be said in
terms of if we live to be
200 maybe we're gonna get how's that
gonna change our behavior in terms of
taking life for granted and not having a
a bookend to sort of arrange your life
around i need to get married this time i
need to procreate at this time i need to
pick a career by this time like the sort
of psychological effects we're going to
have
i'll deal with that later i'll deal with
that later i have all the time in the
world i'm not going to settle
will we stop procreating who knows like
the psychological
effect of i know i'm not going to die
tomorrow because i know on this thing
i'm not gonna have a heart attack i'm
not gonna have a stroke
is there anything to be said for feeling
so i'm just gonna walk through traffic
that
will you take more risks other place in
your life because you feel comfortable
i.e the theory of like how most car
accidents happen five minutes from home
because you're like
comfortable because you live near your
home and that's where it's going to
happen
right yes okay but then you just move
yeah that's how to say that's a problem
just move to a new house i can get you
another sticky
i yeah i don't but i don't want to mess
up your algorithm what if you start
getting marketed like
you know i don't know menopause drugs or
something like does this connect to your
computer
you need more testosterone you start
getting targeted ads for like birth
control like you should not conceive a
child please go on this birth control
immediately
look what's going to happen are you just
going to start being sent ginkgo biloba
your memory sucks we can tell we don't
like any of what's going on in your body
anymore
much estrogen yeah it's just going to be
just going to be sending you
centrum silver like papa pass
this can't be good it's a good
experiment just free metformin trial
okay so but like there's no way to
really quantify
the other effects that this could have
psychologically made
yeah that's true so i've got i've
thought about this
okay okay the agency in life i think
doesn't matter how long you live
i'm still going to enjoy being here just
as much as if i'm gonna you know live
for a thousand years or die tomorrow
that i think is is actual bullshit that
that the longer you live the less
excited you are about life and it comes
from within
and it's also there's such an
interesting sort of um
irony is probably not even the word i
know that word is often misused but the
idea that
you know you're not going to die
tomorrow because of this device that you
wear
but your philosophies also live like
you're going to die tomorrow
exactly that's the trick it's just such
a fascinating two things being true at
once yeah
yeah but the longer you live you're
definitely gonna worry about crossing
the road more
sure that is true is that more because
not because you're
necessarily frail and couldn't heal as
well if you were hit is it more or the
idea of like
i've i've had too many uh
li like i've i'm due
do you know i don't believe in that i i
think that what what you'd want to do
because life be
longer life makes life more valuable
if you go back a hundred years people
would take a lot of risks now
because we live so long right you know
we wear helmets some of us
we try to drive well some of us but
isn't it interesting that wearing a
helmet
like i think about just how how
confusing humans are in terms of our
motives and the things that we normalize
and the things that we've minimized the
risk of just because we do it so much
and we've gotten away with it so much we
forget how dangerous things are
if you're putting a helmet on to do
something you already shouldn't do it do
you know what i'm saying
the idea that we're like it's safe now
it's like no you're already putting
yourself in danger if you're putting the
helmet on right now
skydiving with a helmet yeah that's
gonna you can still break all your bones
and not your brain on the motorcycle but
the idea that we're like
okay we're going to play football with
helmets on so now we're safe whereas
helmet
is what causes the most it's true they
use it they don't wear helmets typically
well they used to
in football the injuries are increasing
because
they're using the helmet as weapons and
there's a false sense of safety if i can
hit my head and wear a helmet
yeah so there's just something about
like like these things that are supposed
to protect us
actually sort of give us the green light
to put ourselves in even more dangerous
situations it makes no sense
right well things like that on my body
make me love life even more i don't want
life to end i'm having a great time
and i also think there's just like the
greatest tragedy of life
that the people that are the wisest
technically have the least amount of
time
like i look i go my mom's in a nursing
home and i i go around and i don't ask
any of my girlfriends for advice
because i love you all but girlfriends
that love you give you the worst advice
right the guy doesn't call maybe he
likes you too much
what maybe his phone's off maybe he's
scared because he just has such a deep
connection with you he's scared of how
much he loves you like
maybe he's on a plane yeah they have
wi-fi on planes like what you know
sometimes you just need someone to like
come
in with that sort of like hard thing
um but uh i just i don't know i was
going on a tangent about how that
fascinates me about how
we you know i think when i go to nursing
homes
i will like knock on an eight-year-old
woman's door and i'm like what does this
text mean and she'll go oh yeah he
doesn't like you
like you just have wisdom that
i'm like what if you die soon there's
all this incredible wisdom in your brain
exactly you upload it to the cloud
that's why i don't want people to
suffer or die young all older people
are hugely valuable hugely to to the
world we send them out to pasture in
this culture
but it's like this is really sad imagine
where we would be
technologically p brilliant people
weren't dying at 70 80. right well my
father's 81 and he's
as fit as a 20 30 year old and he's
contributing to society he's looking
after grandkids he started a new career
at 76 dating bunch of women it it
he's living life but that could be for
everybody he's a role model
for what life can be like in your 80s
and is this is it he's specifically this
healthy
and going to live so much longer because
you're his son
or is this just a coincidence well his
our family typically doesn't live more
than 70 something years old um
years so he's an outlier we'll see you
never know i mean we call it an n of one
experiment which means it's
it's not going to tell you anything but
i do think that uh it's not hurting him
what he's doing and he's
doing basically what i do right he's
been he's a scientist so he can read my
papers
i don't say dad you got to do this he's
a grown man
but he does believe in it and he's been
doing it and his friends are getting old
and he's not
fascinating and then are there certain
things you can do when you're older
that uh stop
damage to your genes that like is
amazing besides smoking or whatever
uh that is like a major thing that a lot
of people are missing
to be better or worse to avoid like
things that we just do to damage our
genes
in a lackadaisical way like i was
listening to you talk about
x-rays and how damaging x-rays are to
uh our dna right our dna our genes
our cells our cells now you're right on
all three i'm the best
even when i'm wrong i'm right it's like
it's a gift no but
but the older you get the more x-rays
you'll probably need
that's wrong
i mean that makes sense to me older
people hurt their ankle more they gotta
get an mri
they gotta get an x-ray the more the
older you are
the higher the chances that you've had
an x-ray that's true but i would rather
have an mri an x-ray
so mri doesn't do the same damage to
cells right
x-rays do why do we not have an ability
to x-ray people
when they're injured or hurt without
damaging their cells why isn't it
because x-ray machines are cheaper than
mris that's the reason but
x-rays trash your dna and if we do that
to a mouse
it ages rapidly how one x-ray
five mine's not gonna kill you but if
you do it consistently
it's a lifetime accumulation all i know
is that when i go in for an x-ray
and i'm gonna talk about my mammogram
story in a second because i feel like
when i went if i went in for my first
mammogram and
the woman it's digital now and there's
like an x-ray maybe it's because my
boobs are fake they had to do an
additional thing
to look for or some under it it was like
a whole nightmare they had to like
take them off and put them back on this
whole thing and so
and so i go in there and the woman
because i've always been
fascinated i just thought it was my
comedian brain about when you go in for
an x-ray
they put a giant metal cape on you
that doesn't cover your head it only
covers your body yep
why are you putting one on my head i
don't like the fact that i'm wearing
this cape to begin with this again this
feels like the helmet thing it feels
like i just shouldn't be doing this at
all if i need this and then they run
away sprint
they run out of the room and duck and
lock the door
yeah and it's dangerous stuff they don't
want to be near it like why am i
in here if you're well if you if you're
not casually walking out the store if
you're sprinting out the store and like
ducking obviously this isn't a good
business model right
so it's not we got to go back to square
it's not ready for market
right i have big fights with doctors and
dentists who want to x-ray me
now you you do need an x-ray once in a
while otherwise you can't see if you've
got cavities but
this every year giving me i don't do
that i've had
big fights with my dentist that you're
not gonna x-ray me and they
basically say well it's all on you don't
come to us if you get a cavity fine but
i don't need sugar
yeah right but i'm thinking yeah you
need to pay for the machine that you
just bought
yeah that's why you want to keep
x-raying me yeah and i don't have any
pain i don't have any issues
so i try to avoid x-rays i try to avoid
cosmic rays as much as i can which are
up in
high up in the altitudes are these like
emfs
like cosmic rays no these are mostly
um particles because that cosmic
rays sounds like a dj at coachella like
you have to understand a lot of these
terms that you use in science the way
they trickle down
normal people are like bands
and like you know what i mean so when i
hear cosmic i just think of
fiction you know good name from a band
yeah totally or like
we have this cosmic connection like i
think of like astrology and things that
you know what i mean that are not
scientific so
okay the sun is spewing out particles
that if you don't get protected by the
atmosphere it'll
damage your dna and damaging your dna
accelerates the aging process yes
that is a fact um so i avoid i try not
to fly too much but i have to
okay so this is what i want to talk
about because but
the x-ray really quick another thing
that happened to me when i was doing the
uh x-ray mammogram the woman walked up
to me
with the metal cape and she just looked
at me
and she went are you gonna have kids oh
no
and i was like i think i probably i
think so and she's like oh let's just
put it on anyway regard like
she wasn't gonna put it on me because i
hadn't had kids yet and i was in my late
three years you can get ovarian cancer
what's the problem but then also why do
i even need this
let's not do this at all whether i have
kids or not even if i don't have kids i
don't want
these rays in my ovaries i have to carry
them around like
it's obviously bad enough to where you
were like
if you're gonna have a kid we're gonna
put this metal over your uterus
yeah it's really bad there's a lot of
things we do in our lives that are crazy
craziness i'm just getting sunburned
like i did yesterday
over at gabby and uh you know larry's
place yeah
but let me ask you but you have this
punk rock uh
you know sort of not disrespect for
authority but the ability to question
most people they think doctors know way
more than
how who am i to question a doctor like
if you're going to give me an extra
obviously this is safe or else someone
would have put a stop to it no one would
just be bombarding
my uterus was something that is
carcinogenic or else there would be some
authority that would stop it like
it just doesn't occur to me to think
when you go to the doctor
to get healed you would ever get sick at
the doctor
doesn't make sense yeah well doctors are
only human and they can only store a
certain amount of
knowledge and it's very hard to keep up
to date with the science they're usually
10 years behind actual knowledge
i work at harvard medical school so i
have to say some of my best
colleagues and friends are doctors but
but my physician
um laughter is the best medicine also so
i'm also a doctor should i say
i'll give you a phd i don't know if you
guys know this but laughter is the best
medicine i know you guys are working on
a lot of like
antibiotics and stuff have you seen my
stand up special
let's talk about medicine we now are
taking a break of this incredibly
insightful
informative life-changing
earth-shattering interview with dr david
sinclair
to talk about fashion and how good i am
at it
it's no surprise that i'm a fashion icon
i want to let you know
my taste is flawless my instincts
perfect well we brought everyone here
many of us say i'm the next anna wintour
okay well i wanna let you know that we
brought everyone here because this is an
intervention
everything whitney wears looks like she
pulled it from the funeral of a muppet
this is a video that um i think you'll
be informed celebrating my fashion
instincts yeah i just thought this would
be a good this is a good showcase of why
you need stitch fix
and why you need a company that is going
to i love stitch fix
we send you so and i think this this
will show you why
oh hello like whitney cummings does your
closet also look like a secondhand store
is it filled with patterns and prints
that even even the worst of the fabric
stores wouldn't sell
even joanne said no thanks here's the
thing i buy
pieces that spark joy they don't match
anything else and i keep them
but some of your clothes have to match
which is where stitch fix is really
helpful
because the stylist will pick you things
that go together and just mail it right
to your house
why would icon celebrity legend whitney
cummings need
a service like stitch fix let us show
you clothing like this
she's 37. many of you don't know this
but whitney cummings in her free time
also works as a cabana boy
at casinos all over the nation
where are you dealing blackjack wait
that is a
tiger print pajama top
slash like bahama vibe every time i wear
it
you should be arrested just like the
tiger king every time i wear it people
try to buy drugstore
stitches would never send you that they
would never send you that shirt
because their styles hand select things
based on the quiz you take and nowhere
on the quizzes and say you want to look
stupid
do you want no one to ever lend you
money yeah wear this top you want
something to close their eyes as they
pass you in the street do you want to
lose that court case wear this shirt
the thing about whitney cummings in her
fashion is that she doesn't dress to
impress
she dresses to depress because every
time i see her i want to kill myself
okay i see your point so stitch fix you
take a quiz
which i did for you okay it was quick
easy to ask me a couple
questions you know how much you spend on
tops how much you spend on dresses how
much money on shoes where do you shop
what's your sizes what do you like gave
me a couple options literal
visual options of would you wear this
would you not wear this
and then they build this intelligent
uh kind of system so that their stylists
know what to package you
send it to your house you keep what you
want you send back what you don't
and it comes out of your stitch fix
styling budget and you only pay twenty
dollars
styling fee for each box this is like i
don't have
class or taste so this is i'm basically
all i'm doing is paying 20
for the styling fee for each box which
gets credited towards pieces
you keep and there are no hidden fees it
seems
to be true there's a reason being a
stylist is a job
so they offer clothing hand selected by
expert stylist for unique size
style and budget also i can't try things
on i ca like they just handle all of it
for you right
all right get started today it's
stitchfix.com
whitney and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything
in your fix that's stitchfix.com
whitney for 25 off when you keep
everything in
your fix stitchfix.com
whitney don't dress like whitney just
use your code you know i'm not proud of
this but it's no secret
that the good for you team we're a
filthy bunch we're stinky bunch
we put ourselves in disgusting
situations this is
why we
have a company mandate that everyone
must have
native body wash and native deodorant at
all times
i put dogs on my face
we roll around in pig bogs uh
on a on a work day and
no one needs more native body wash or
shower gel
or deodorant than the good for you team
i lay around with horses
i i we have cake fights we have food
fights constantly
we are in a constant state of soil
soiling ourselves for your entertainment
and native body wash is the only thing
that keeps us clean i'm obsessed with
the lavender and rose
that is the best my favorite body wash
set they have lavender rose
i really like the peach nectar one oh
really because you are just
cause i am just i'm just pain
it's the only thing that keeps us clean
because also i have to wash my body so
much that i can't use something that's
super abrasive and not natural
or else i'm going to dry my skin out and
we know that my biggest nightmare in
life is my skin being dry i have to be
lubed up at all times because that's
what ages you is when you use abrasive
things
that destroy your skin and my biggest
nightmare is having a sunburn
and somebody on this team
thinks we're sunflowers i am very has us
outside
face up to the sun the sun care by
native is brand new
this is me locked out of a car for hours
because who knows how to work a tesla
so you need sunscreen no idea i
definitely need it apparently you have
emily editing a seven hour video by the
pool
and she's in a full suit or something it
is my
duty as an employer to provide mineral
health because sunscreen a lot of
sunscreens have nasty chemicals and shit
in them
they're not and they hurt the
environment a lot of them native
made a sunscreen that is mineral
sunscreen it is i'm obsessed with it the
way that it smells is amazing
it doesn't make you tear up when it gets
in your eye
it is like perf the perfect sunscreen
and i can subscribe to it i can have it
shipped right to my house i have to go i
don't have to
you know go into target look around for
it for a hour as soon as i'm done
with the bottle i have a new one at my
door so i'm never i'm no excuse to be
filthy ever anyway and when i subscribe
to it i saved 25 percent heller
so without further ado i'm just gonna
tell you that you need to stay fresh
stay
clean with native by going to native
d-o-d-e-o
dot com slash whitney or use promo code
whitney at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's native
d e o dot com slash whitney or use promo
code whitney
at checkout for 20 off your first order
so so let's talk about these the raise
because i think
there's also a generalized anxiety that
ages us when we're worrying about things
that either we don't need to be worrying
about
or that we can't control at all so
you've laid out so clearly
in this book all the things that age you
like physically i'm
sort of interested in the things we do
mentally and emotionally i know people
that
eat kale exclusively and
eat healthier and very rigid about what
they eat they do yoga every day and
they're
not healthy people they're sick people
they're neurotic they're obsessive
they're you know
you can sort of be doing physically
healthy things and not necessarily be a
healthy person
for sure i mean if you do just one good
thing and the rest of your life
you might eat kale but you smoke forget
it that's not gonna help if you
if you're obsessive and you're stressed
eating kale's not gonna help you the
fact that human beings
still smoke they know the side it's they
know the side effects what
is is that just an inherent is that an
inherited
ability to just be delusional is that
a mental illness that someone would be
doing that in this day and age as
someone that like likes to smoke and
would
probably do it if i it didn't was
healthy if i didn't think it was gonna
make my lips
old i do it's vanity alone the oh i just
got i don't like doing the dry cleaning
you just smell disgusting and then i
don't want to get those lines around my
lips and or yellow nails otherwise i
would totally do it but
what how can so many humans smoke how do
we explain that
knowing it's killing them well it's
called addiction but yeah but there's
also the
people like to put stuff in their mouths
uh like to chew on stuff suck on stuff
so my grandmother smoked for most of her
life
and when she quit she still for the rest
of her life had to put something in her
mouth mm-hmm
toothpick something like that she
actually used what are those
cigarette holders she would oh yeah she
won't know yeah so she did good then she
probably didn't get the wrinkles or the
life hack okay now i'm gonna smoke again
they still make those
i'll get them in a vintage store yes
cigarette holder so that it's
yeah but also that was back in the day
when you know i'm
um contradicting myself because i'm
obsessed with looking
back at things doctors prescribed 50
years ago like i mean they used to
prescribe smoking to pregnant women to
calm down and relax
sure and heroin was great a lot of
things prescribed that
now are toxic there was this weight loss
drug actually that
in the 1920s that a lot of people took
what is it called dnp and it was found
it was actually part of a bomb uh bomb
chemicals and the people who were making
the bombs were very skinny
so they figured out if you eat it you
lose a lot of weight the problem is that
it revs up the body so much you
basically overheat and die
so that led to what we now call the fda
but uh what we need is a pill like that
that's safe
uh which is this is another story but
that's something that i'm working on is
to
to get that weight loss pill but we're
getting off track
if we had a cure for smoking that you
could just go like that
that would save millions millions of
lives just in the us but and i i just
the the addiction i talk about a lot on
this podcast
as someone that is uh admittedly
an addict uh thankfully i didn't get the
substances
i got the perfectionism the workaholism
um the you know cleanliness like i have
what i like to call like good addictions
they weren't necessarily good addictions
in my 20s until i was able to kind of
uh alchemize them into benefiting me
instead of
destroying me and other people um
addiction to being liked having you know
too many friends over exhausting myself
and going to this party and this dinner
and this dinner
which is an addiction looking back but
because it's socially acceptable i
no one would think to do an intervention
on having too many friends or being too
nice
well yeah you've done all right miss uh
so but but you're getting better right
you've learned to control it i think so
but but but when i think about
addiction and how this is kind of the
curve ball in a lot of this where people
like okay
i'm addicted to alcohol is there any
biological basis
for addiction that we're missing i also
think addiction
the way that you classify aging as a
disease a lot of people don't understand
to classify
addiction as a disease they don't think
that it you know gets progressive over
time and needs to be treated and
you can't stop it yourself we think if
you have lyme disease you're going to
treat it if you have alzheimer's you're
going to treat it
if you have aging or addiction people
like i guess that's just who you are
that's really well put um and just in
the same way aging is the disease
which is something that leads to
sickness and eventually death if you
don't
do something about it addiction is the
same but people are
susceptible to it a lot of people i'm
smokers
drug addicts this is something that
we're born with it's not something we
should
you know vilify mm-hmm and you and you
said something
in i believe uh i think it was on
rogan's podcast
um you know because i've always been
told i'm in
programs like alanon and codependents
anonymous where you go in and just
reprogram your brain and so that you
don't repeat
the uh cycles the toxic cycles that you
saw growing up in terms of how
relationships should be how people
should be treated how you should behave
if you saw parents fighting a lot you
think that's normal and then you're in
these
you know dating these pugnacious people
and then all these like cantankerous
relationships that are just stressful
because you just think it's normal
you know or i you know and this is
something to talk about too sort of the
addictions we're born with right like
the same way you can be born addicted to
oxycontin or a crack baby that you know
was popularized
in the 80s born addicted to it you can
also technically be born with like an
adrenaline addiction
if your mother in utero was stressed out
and
fighting a lot right and then i had this
natural just
comfort in drama i felt alive in a time
of crisis
when i didn't have adrenaline or wasn't
in something stressful or chaotic
i was actually scared because i was
always waiting for the shoe to drop i
thrive
in chaos that's my comfort zone other
people
it would stress them out it stresses me
out when there's not some kind of chaos
because then i know the chaos is gonna
come and then i'm just waiting for
the damocles sword to drop that explains
a lot actually now i understand you
but do you have adhd or do you have what
we'd call laser focused disease
i've been diagnosed with a litany of
mental limitations
adhd is one of them yes
but you can become obsessed i don't have
it with you because you're interesting
you're not obsessed with me i am
obsessed with you but i'm not distracted
by anything when i'm talking to you
so there's the laser focus i think that
that is the key to success
that you do a lot of things you're
interested in a lot of things you get
bored
but when you need to do something you
really do i don't get bored if
something's not boring
so for me this is sort of the issue i
think with the way that there's so many
flaws in the way that we teach
kids every kid learns differently if a
kid is getting bored in class
teach differently or get them in a
different class they might just be too
advanced for this they might
already know it they might it's just not
you know where they should
like for me when people are like god
you're so restless and you can't like
sit through a movie i'm like i will walk
out of a movie if 20 minutes in
i'm bored and i was like why can't you
just sit there why would i i'm leaving
and people are like you're so adhd it's
like no i'll stay if it's great
why do i have to why do we pathologize
people
that take an action or
are able to have enough self-respect and
respect for their time
to abort something if it's boring to
them yeah boredom is the worst
i can't stand it i it's like my head's
going to explode if i get bored
it's it's it's you know for me but that
is like what drive would
be part of what makes you so successful
this is
the thing although it's stressful living
life like that because you can never
stop that's why i won't never satisfied
that's right well i never want to
pathologize it because i'm like if
you're bored and restless in a meeting
at your work go start your own business
because that's the kind of brain that is
going to build
like we need you we don't need you in a
cubicle we need you to go start a
business because you have a gifted brain
if you get bored easily i think yeah i
think those are the people that change
the world
those people who are never satisfied and
that they they hate boredom
and then however when you're doing
studies
and you have to re does it ever get
monotonous in a way
to where you have to stick with
something because
being a scientist can be really boring
like you can't just abandon a
experiment because it was like getting
boring and i have to watch this my mouse
run around again well the good thing
about science is that
uh once you're through the early stages
where you have to work
through seven days a week 24 hours
you're always on pretty much
but i'm not the one that has to stay up
all night anymore i just dream and i go
and i
think of new things and try and make new
medicines and because if you're too
bogged down in those logistics you can't
step back from the bird's eye view and
have these
big ideas right and this is the problem
that
a scientist has to be able to do by
minutia so i have to think
at the nano scale level on atoms and
chemicals
but also think about the planet what
does the planet need and how do you
take that and fix that mm-hmm and that
that
if i was just doing experiments with
test tubes all day i couldn't do that
so i'm now free to do that which is the
best but your kind of personality
did you have to actively allow yourself
to delegate because
i'm the kind of person that's like i
want to delegate i but i also have a
little bit of
guilt if i'm not doing it but there's
also a little bit of
okay there's no way they did that right
i'm gonna have to double check oh
there's your problem
that's why you're stressed out i'm
really lazy i don't like doing stuff
clearly
so i just find people that do those jobs
better than me yeah and there's lots of
jobs that people can do that are better
than me writing grants
doing experiments really anything
writing stuff and i think that's the
outsourcing the life hack for that is
having the
skill to hire well and i finally have a
team in my life that i can go you edit i
don't even need to look at it
but if you're micromanaging it doesn't
necessarily mean you have a personality
flaw means you just
have the wrong team that's right so yeah
surround yourself with people that are
better than you
at whatever they do that's the key and
i'm i've hired some real
really useless people use them an
experiment but
that the other thing that andre i guess
he wrote in his book which i admire is
he says
if somebody's a screw up get rid of them
yesterday and i'm i'm
i'm quite kind so i i struggle firing
people
and i wish that i'd done that more so
that's my life lesson anyone who's
listening
surround yourself with kind people and
get rid of the assholes i have a no
asshole's policy in my whole
life now that's right and also asshole
is subjective
just because someone's hurting your
feelings doesn't mean they're an asshole
you might be overly sensitive
but i'm just saying you might be
projecting like because i think in my
field it requires so much
um everyone's so emotional and sensitive
in my field that if someone's like yeah
do it this way
or just directness comes off as bitchy
or asshole
when it's actually just the nicest thing
someone can be with
me or anyone directing a movie making a
pocket is direct because that saves the
most time
i don't mind truthfulness yeah that's
what i look for yeah it's
the behind your back oh yeah no that's
that's not okay and i think that the way
that i was able to get around how hard
it was for me to fire people because i
don't want to be a bad person
is that when we are participate in a
negative consequence for someone then
they get to grow and learn we're giving
them a gift
yeah sure
i keep saying that i guess it david's it
clarifies you in your field it ruins
your life but in my field it but doesn't
kill you makes you stronger
your whole thing is you need adversity
to stay young i'm keeping you young by
firing you
that is true go find someone else who
might like you
but you have to have such a zero
tolerance policy
because of how high stakes what you do
is like do you ever
go i can't believe i'm like in driving
the
the sort of vehicle that is leading
humanity in a certain direction doesn't
feel like
pressure sometimes
um no i'm enjoying myself a lot
it does get frustrating when it when
somebody's useless at doing stuff
yeah and my lab is a bit like a
kindergarten i bring in
young kids in their early 20s and some
of them are just untrainable but most of
them because i'm at harvard
we get really smart kids and it's a joy
to see them
most of them are smarter than me
probably all of them actually
and so they can do programming they can
do this and that and i just say
here's the problem that i want fixed you
three go solve that
and it's just an amazing thing there's
also the more freedom you give someone
the more creative they're going to be
and invested
yeah so my my advice to anybody
especially scientists is don't don't
worry about today's technology
often people think oh we can do this so
let's just use that technology to solve
that
forget that just come to me with a good
question
and let's solve it and make if we have
to invent new technology we'll do that
but it's the question you want to start
with are there any
um ideas you've had for experiments and
studies that you were like ah
like that like there's jokes that i have
that i'm like i've worked on i've tried
it's like
it's just not the time or i haven't
cracked it or it's not what is there
anything that's like your
white whale of i would just need more
money or i would need more time or i'd
have to give all my time to it like is
there
there's thousands of that one that got
away yeah because you have to make
choices sophie's choice in terms of your
time
yeah it's true and studying aging is you
can't do the experiment overnight even
to look at a mouse's lifespan takes two
and a half three years
and you can only do that certain amount
of times in your career
there is no one's ever asked me that
this is really good
there is one theory that i never got
around to finishing testing
slash proving hopefully and it's called
xenohermesis terrible name
xeno means between species and hormesis
i mentioned which is what doesn't kill
you makes you live longer
right the idea is that if you stress
plants and eat them
you get the benefits of the molecules
that they're producing to survive
and can i ask you a question about how
to stress
a plant besides let it live with me but
how do you stress out a plant
it's easy uh people who make red wine do
that all the time
don't water it uh put a bright light
let caterpillars eat it fungus
you know the problem with the food that
we get at the regular supermarket
is that it's in perfect conditions it
grows quickly but it's not full of those
xeno-hermetic molecules that i think
give us this pseudo
pseudo adversity and then the whole
vegetable thing
let's discuss because obviously you know
your thing is eat the stressed out
plant so that you don't have to stress
you're going to get the benefits of
eating the stressed out plant
is the way that we prepare food procure
food
at all uh vegetables at all undoing any
of those benefits so it's like
you know there's i get paranoid
sometimes i'm like ah but all these
fertilizers are on it and
and is eating this i'm i'm eating a
stressed out plant that's supposed to be
good for me but it's covered in
chemicals like is this
is this just the vehicle now that i'm
putting antibiotics in my body because
they spray it with fertilizers and crab
and then when you cook it you cook all
the vitamins out of it what's the point
of even eating this
yeah well that's the problem with
agriculture today they want them to grow
fast so they
they put all these chemicals on them
make sure there's not no
chewing like you want it to be perfect
there's no caterpillar marks on them but
these are
these are very happy plants you don't
want to eat happy plants do we need to
be worried about gmos the way
a lot of people don't do but i care
about you hate mail
come at me there's nothing wrong with
jim gmo
what did i say you said gmo oh uh
so the those who are against gmo there's
no evidence that gmo is bad for you in
fact
there are tens of millions of people who
die particularly kids
every year people go blind from a lack
of vitamin a across the planet
and there are plants that produce
vitamin a
genetically that are banned by countries
and europe just banned gmo even recently
crispr you know the genome was banned in
europe
the reason that was political that was
not based on science
the french particularly wanted to
protect their farmers from u.s imports
ah
okay so i i've seen no evidence and i'm
a scientist
that gmo is bad i mean it feels bad it
sounds like it
would be bad we've been changing the
genetics of plants for the last 10 000
years at least
you think that tomatoes are that big and
blueberries are that big in the wild no
we and corn is this big normally we've
been mutating these plants for for
thousands of years and we're not scared
of those plants
but if we go in and change one gene very
accurately
then suddenly it's gmo we can't eat it
we can't save kids lives or block you
know their eyesight that's ridiculous
it is interesting it makes me think of
how you know we
sabotage ourselves with our own emotions
and imaginations of like well i
read it on the internet so much to be
true how you know this sort of
access to information for the first time
people have access to
you people can listen to can talk to you
and listen to you on podcasts for talk
for three hours like
you know this is an unprecedented level
of access to
accurate information now but there's
also an unprecedented
access to information that is not true
and people's like emotional need to sort
of believe things that
sound right to them with absolutely no
degree in any of this
is that something we're programmed to do
because it's so
bad for us like why i'm just obsessed
with our
instincts that hurt us anti-survival
instincts
yeah you've hit upon a few really good
points one is that
we scientists never used to be able to
speak to the public much
we used to go on npr and that would be
it uh
and then everything i used to say in the
2000s to reporters in newspapers
it was never accurate stupid headline
harvard professor says we're going to
live forever
they would drive me nuts yeah i barely
speak to them
they stay in business by morphing what
you say into something that is just
shocking and at the expense of our
credibility yeah
it was really bad and then the public
thinks oh sinclair's cured aging which
was
ridiculous but then the irony is that
upton sinclair
perhaps a distant relative
sort of was the first muckraker right
who would go in the 20s uh definitely
not a relative
okay my name's made up
you're speechless for the first time
you're speechless what do you mean
what did you did you did you make up a
fake one my father made up a fake one
obsessed do you know what it was before
of course was it something horrible like
cummings but you had to change it no it
wasn't that bad
that's fascinating to me it was tsigati
which is a hungarian
name which means little island and he
went to australia
in the 50s and he was called a foreigner
award we
they get called so sinclair my my his
mother my grandmother was
married to mr lewis so sinclair lewis
sounded good
it does authoritative has the word sin
in it yeah
a little wink wink to your ancestry so
yeah i'm not related to any singles but
uh
yeah it's not a bad name i like it it's
very
um there's something really fascinating
to me about how
many judgments we make even if we don't
admit it to ourselves based on someone's
name
and it's so it really makes me realize
my internalized misogyny
if i'm about to have a big meeting with
a lawyer named tiffany i'm like
what is that that's so unfair this is
why i'm worried about the neural link i
don't want anyone to hear my thoughts or
see what i'm thinking because my first
thought
is always sexist offensive it's like
you know what we say in 12-step programs
is you're responsible
um for your first action but not your
first thought because your first thought
is old it's based out of fear
it's your something you inherited it's
your dad's point of view your
grandmother's point of view it's
something toxic and
wrong fear-based judgmental critical
it's like our lord of the flies instinct
and then we go like i it happens to me
i'm gonna say it this is gross to say
but we have to start talking and
admitting this
if neural link is gonna come along and
everyone's just gonna be able to read
everything that we think we're gonna
have to play defense on this or get some
protocols in place to be a little more
forgiving with people's inner monologues
because when i see a female pilot walk
on the plane i'm like
first off first especially if it's a
tiffany
pilot tiffany here tiffany sinclair
loading up to go to boston you'd be like
you know what i think i'm gonna step off
this flight
but then i go no no no no that's my
primordial reptilian brain
having an irrational reaction but then i
go no no she's a pilot
she's a woman in a male-dominated field
she probably had to work twice as hard
to get half as far she's probably better
than the men
it takes me a second such a sexist
that's
terrible totally i'm totally have
internalized misogyny
that comes from i'm gonna blame every
movie i've ever seen in every magazine
i've ever read
it's not conscious it's just sort of
like what i
the blueprint i have to actively coach
myself out of it
same thing with guys when i see like a
you know a guy go on stage stand up i'm
like here we go
you're gonna be the like my wife's such
a nag joke i'm like what do you mean
maybe he's gonna go on and talk about
how his heart is broken and he's
suffering from depression like
i these stereotypes we have in our heads
that are supposed to protect us and keep
things simple
are actually sabotaging us it really is
i mean it just makes life simpler if you
can just judge someone without even
bothering to get to know them mm-hmm
but yeah it's it's a problem right
because nobody's
really who you think they are are you
going to do neurolink brains like yours
can't just broadcast
their thoughts to people uh no that
would be scary if you knew what was
going on in there
i know but someone like you like
knurling technology which is gonna be
able to project people's thoughts that
will happen in our lifetime right or
read people's thoughts
not really not gonna happen i don't i'm
not on the same page
they don't call me hoe rogan for no
reason
i like to talk about neurolink and how
it's weeks away
well it'll it'll help with diseases like
parkinson's whatever but downloading
your brain
not now lifetime i'm afraid but someone
like you is your brain insured like you
know
jlo's butt is insured there's guitarists
whose hands are insured
uh i am insured that is for sure there's
key man insurance in a bunch of
companies
so i guess you call that fascinating and
then also when it comes to the longevity
and there's
there's a couple things i want to get to
that are sort of in a different space
but
when it comes to longevity is this going
to be i think about evolution
a lot i'm obsessed with it even though i
probably can't articulate
anything any ideas i have about it or
sort of
instincts but be these next so let's say
resveratrol
uh nmn um nad
let's say you have to be somewhat
privileged to have access to these at
least let's say financially if you're
going to spend say 300
a month on the pills and
um uh let's say healthy food is going to
be a little more expensive although if
you're fasting you're probably going to
buy less of it so maybe it's not
um uh it is cheaper to fast here you
know cheaper to fast uh life hack
we can safely kind of say you have you
have to have access to podcasts
access to a phone and order an internet
to be able to listen to these podcasts
to even ascertain this correct
information
is this the new darwinism in a way
going to be financial because of what
people do and don't have access to
and how they're going to be able to it's
already like that
right not everybody listens to your
podcast
um what not every there are a few people
right now
column
[Music]
my heart rate just goes to 250 a minute
who's gonna have
access to this so when you talk about
being able to cut a finger off
and regenerate the finger right who's
gonna have access to this type of
technology
first and is that gonna radically
is it going to cause riots what's going
to happen well this has been happening
for the last few hundred years
well maybe longer but 100 years ago the
rich were flying
of course uh and that access to also
this is what happens with technology
but it eventually becomes democratized i
once said
everyone can fly and then i got
apparently you know a lot of people who
can't fly but it's a lot cheaper than it
used to be put it that way oh fly on
airplanes you mean
well yeah you can
um where there's a will there's a way i
was like maybe i just missed that
really we put wings on i wouldn't be
surprised
like you're hanging out with laird
hamilton he puts like you know he can
make surfboards fly through the wall i
mean who knows what's
going on up there so so i'm trying to
democratize everything i'm trying to
make these bio buttons uh on our chest
really cheap drugs cheap the tests that
tell you how old you are
make that really cheap so that everybody
can have these technologies not just for
the wealthy few
but right now there are a fair number of
wealthy few who
really are taking care of their bodies
and i think are going to live a lot
longer than the rest of us
do you think there will be a day where
you know and i know people get all
paranoid about this and
this is not me going down like a q a
rabbit hole in terms of like the vaccine
injects a chip and you that's it will
there be a day
where when you apply for a job you have
to sort of
sort of be fully transparent about the
vitamins you take about how you're
taking care of like
you know so it's like if i'm making a
decision between a 25 year old and a 40
year old
and that 40 year old can make a case to
me that's like
i'm more valuable than 25 year old
because this is i'm actually younger
biologically than that person
yeah but that that works to your
advantage if you've taken care of your
body
so you can be 65 70 and show up and say
i'm actually 40
hire me right right that'd be great yeah
i mean that's fascinating to me because
because there's this clash right now of
like i can't hire an older person
because they don't know dropbox and
technology and instagram but a younger
person is like entitled and sensitive
and it's going to cancel me for saying
you know there's just like it i feel
like there's going to be an interesting
middle ground that's going to have more
sort of justice and merit in the future
when it's like yeah i'm 40 but i'm
might as well be 25. well you can prove
that you're 25 biologically with these
tests
that we're working on so that there's
going to come a day i think where
in the next few years you'll know your
biological age for not
a lot of will you put that on your
dating app or your real age
wow my biological age is 25.
i'm 50. we can even tell you how old
your ovaries are
oh no i got those x-rays i wore the
apron
there's a lot of of uh i've been hearing
you talk about
sort of fertility and the advancements
in fertility now when it comes to
genetics yeah well i don't know about
people
but i do know about about horses and
mice we can reverse infertility in those
animals
and we're not too different from those
uh so if it's true
what we see in the mice is that we could
take a 65 year old woman
and make her fertile again now i'm going
to get crisis because we don't know that
for a fact
but i'm just saying if it extrapolates
that's what we'll be living with um
so we're trying that and it's
interesting because
you know when i think about i'm obsessed
with like the biological basis for
things like my brain just needs to know
why this was advantageous to
the human and why they evolved in this
direction so it's like
women evolved to stop being fertile
later in life i guess because the life
expectancy was so
low and it wasn't necessary but you know
i would say back in the day
that's a scientific term uh thousands of
years ago it would have been more
advantageous to give birth young because
you would be healthier you'd be able to
defend your child
in a more robust way you may so many
women died on childbirth maybe your
chances of surviving were higher but my
brain goes the older you are
the better a mother you're going to be
because you're going to know more you're
going to be more patient you're going to
select
a more qualified partner like 65 is
probably when you should
start having kids frankly absolutely
that's when people finally figure their
shit out
right and that's when you have the least
amount of time it's true i
i totally agree don't get married till
65. that's a that's a really good idea
as long as i don't look 65 i feel like
i'll be fine uh well
so humans and even mice female mice lose
their fertility about halfway through
their lifespan
so this idea that women stop giving
birth because
it's dangerous i don't think that's true
because mice also do
and mice don't die from having little
pubs
but what i think is is going on is that
the reproductive system is just
fragile um and there are other parts of
our bodies that continue on
way beyond where we should be i mean the
reason we age actually is that we just
were not selected to live beyond about
45 because we were probably going to die
from a war famine
or whatever uh and we're just at the
whim of
entropy now we just fall apart after age
but there are plenty of species that
live a lot longer than that for
thousands of years so we just need to
re-engineer ourselves
it's a big part of your job as you're
you know developing all these
technologies to combat aging
you know is the speed at which dangerous
you know technologies and uh pollutants
because of climate change and how toxic
air is getting and how toxic
you know emfs are or you know can i say
free radicals i don't even know where
that's a real thing
coming through um it's almost like
your technology has to be twice as good
to keep up with how toxic things are
getting it's almost like
it almost just cancels out how dangerous
the world is getting
how can you ever get ahead of how
quickly
our environment is becoming more and
more unhealthy
uh i'm i'm almost speechless because
that's the topic of the book that i'm
writing
oh uh we're on this treadmill written by
david sinclair and when he comes we
haven't talked about this right
okay well don't write a book i'm just
fascinated by the treadmill you have to
chase
yeah in terms of in 20 years will all
your anti-aging advancements just take
us back to the age we should be and
cancel everything out you know yeah we
have to keep
engineering our way out of the problems
we've had ever since we picked up a
stick
as a tool because i'm thinking about you
and i'm thinking about i've read so much
about how
you know conscious you are the you know
environment and such because it's like
none of your stuff is going to work
if the environment gets more and more
unhealthy and food gets more and more
toxic
exactly right but we have to fix both we
have to fix our our lifestyle our
environment
and our bodies that we inherited from
our ancestors who didn't care if we
lived beyond 50.
can i ask you about fear and inherited
fear
and you know in terms of you know
family consolation is not a science
obviously it's it's you probably never
even heard of it it wouldn't even get to
you it's sort of the idea that we
have inherited guilt and shame from our
ancestors whether
you know it's it's just what we grew up
in whether it's you know
i i you really changed my life because
hearing a
uh someone is renowned and brilliant as
you say
that we are not essentially in cages
sort of built by what we've inherited
and our dna
i've always told in addiction programs
that genetics
loads the gun environment pulls the
trigger so in my head it's always been
kind of 50 50.
and i've had a lot of reservations about
having kids because i'm like i don't
want to pass on the mental illness i
don't want to pass on the addiction
like is it inhumane for me to even
procreate
given how i'm going to load this kid up
with sort of
you know a bad deck of cards and in
hearing you say
like you know i think it was 20 you're
like 20 of your life is kind of ordained
by your genetics and i went oh okay then
i think i'll have kids
then the it's not my fault it's a fuck
up it's only 20
my fault right you know so yeah you
inspired me that because i think that so
many of us feel like we are
imprisoned by the bad choices of our
ancestors and the bad habits that we
inherited and we feel like hopeless like
this is just my blueprint and i'm just
i'm turning into my mom there it is and
we have no real control
you know over our destiny because of
what we have inherited that said
you know i'm obsessed with these two
studies that you're going to probably uh
debunk right now or tell me i've got
them wrong about
um there were mice that were
electrocuted every time they smelled a
cherry blossom
and then their offspring when they
smelled a cherry blossom would recoil so
they inherited
this sort of fear to keep themselves
safe just in one generation of mice and
then how babies like will
sort of uh recoil at a picture of a
spider even they don't really know what
a spider is
how we inherit these fears how does that
imprint onto our dna
well it it sounds feasible i don't know
about that particular study but
i did it i i brought a bunch of babies
into my house and i just spiders at them
they see you're just
making this up as you go i'm a rogue
scientist
but it is true and we've done this in my
lab we've published this that if you
have if you take a mouse and make it fat
then the kids that are born are going to
be predisposed to type 2 diabetes
so that there's this whole other layer
of inheritance but is it because they're
they're watching their parents be obese
not at all it's in the womb the way the
genes are expressed turned on and off
is dictated by how the mum behaved so
you can have a big influence on your
baby
is the biological basis of that
your mom was in an environment or dad
whatever
where being obese was auspicious and
beneficial
therefore you're probably going to grow
up in the same environment as them this
will be beneficial to you which is why
we're passing this on
yes right that's exactly right because
genes
don't change much but the what we call
the epigenome
i'm sure you know this but not everyone
does we got the genes the genome and the
epigenome epigenome is the
the reader of the genes the control
system
um and so i guess this is the the basic
instructions
and then this is the reader of that but
you're going to let me finish i'm not
going to interrupt david sinclair are
you insane
it's not that crazy because i'll lose my
train of thought because i know adhd so
let me
okay so the the idea is that the
epigenome is affected by the environment
and our health in the future as well as
our health as a baby
is largely epigenetic
so your genes are not your destiny the
the geneticists
ruled the 20th century but the
epigeneticists are
ruling the 21st century and how
consciously
do you have to act to unprogram
the instincts or or um
epigenetics of your ancestors even your
own parent
in order to stop
the um sort of like marionette operator
that drives you with those inherited
fears and that that are designed to keep
you safe it's just that our
genetics don't know that you know like i
know people that are like deathly
afraid of heights i think everyone
should kind of be afraid of heights but
there's some people or people that are
just like uh i know someone that's
really scared of like
salad and green vegetables or really
scared of certain things and it's like
well maybe
you had an ancestor that like ate
putrified lettuce and got
septic or so you know who knows like
maybe there's something to these
irrational fears maybe these are
actually superpowers
and your body is so psychic and is we
are so
wired to have our bodies remember
what hurt or killed our ancestors for
sure that it drives us
yeah yeah there's science behind that
that that's how the epigenome works
we have can i get a little scientific
here please okay so the dna is just a
chemical string with four letters a c t
g that's just a piece of
chemical it's it's it's inert but what
controls it
in the cell are chemicals that get added
onto that dna
there's one called a methyl which we can
read and that's how we determine your
biological age we map those
changes over time but those methyls are
actually controlling
whether that gene for a solid phobia is
on or off
right and so your genes aren't always on
your environment determines in
some part whether it's turned on or off
does
being pregnant turn them on or off like
you know when women they get pregnant
all of a sudden like
they're super scared of eggs and you're
like what or they're super
pickles yes yes your body is changing
the way your genes are turned on and off
every second right now as you listen to
me your genes are
being turned on and off in your brain
and permanently changed
this is happening all the time and and
the longer we do the good things in life
the better we are at having a healthy
genome epigenome and genome
and we can read that i know that i'm
asking a scientist a question that can
never be proven
but can our irrational fears today
tell us anything about the trauma
or peril of our ancestors yes why do you
think we're afraid of snakes and spiders
that's
humanity that's in innate why do you
think we love sitting around a fire
because tribes that hated fire are all
extinct
right so yeah what we love and what we
hate
comes from our distant past and then
what's the difference between that
and like allergies nothing nothing
i don't know what i'm saying are
allergies designed to keep us safe are
they just
maladaptive things yeah that's
maladaptive okay yeah i mean
there's a good reason to have mast cells
go crazy when there's something foreign
in your body right right
you you've got to keep foreign out but
the allergies is just overreacting
right right pollen's not going to kill
you and is that someone who is um
illegal is that our is that the virgin
are
people that have allergies with someone
that has a bunch of them are these the
people that are
you know um equivalent to
the giraffes that weren't evolved to eat
the
lettuce lettuce lettuce in the trees the
salad trees in africa
you know the cabbage uh christmas trees
they make
uh like i'm just picturing a giraffe
eating eating arugula
but whatever those trees are called um
that are
their necks evolved obviously to be high
enough to reach them right the ones that
couldn't reach it are those
like people with allergies today are we
people that are
it would have died out yeah if it's bad
enough yeah and a lot of us that should
have died out a hundred years ago are
alive just by the skin of our body
well all of us should be dead none of us
are equipped to survive in the world
anymore it's our tools that have allowed
us to survive do you think that's part
of why we have this like
you don't seem to have it because you
have such a control over your destiny
it's it it seems like like you have a
strong understanding of what's going to
keep you safe in the future and keep you
healthy where a lot of us are like is it
this is it this should i drink diet coke
should i not should i drink wine should
i not some people say it's bad some
people don't
avocados are bad now like this water is
poison like we don't have the facts so
we're just constantly persevering and
worrying and assuming we're being lied
to
and whatever and um my
question is like um hold on i'm gonna
get to it hold on
i looked at you and then i thought about
you losing your train of thought and i
was like don't lose your trade of
thought
and here i am i just manifested it um
is there something to be said for
there's this war on anxiety right now
everyone's obsessed with i've anxiety
i know a lot of people that have
legitimate anxiety disorders they can't
leave their bed they can't function they
can't go to work
i'm not a doctor i can't diagnose if
there's something else going on there i
don't know
but i i think that because having
anxiety served us so well in the past
in terms of we got to get out of here
this is we should plan for the future we
should
keep some of this food instead of eat it
all right now what anxiety helped us
and now there's an anxiety that's
obsolete just a a
low-grade anxiety i think we all kind of
have and i always
wonder if some of that has to do with
the fact that we're only superficially
at the top of the food chain
it's like most animals could probably
kill us if they wanted to
we can die from a bee a bee can kill us
a tiny thing this big can kill us
we are pathetic we are trash bags full
of blood
we are a lollipop with a body that's a
stick and a giant head that's all we are
we
we know in some love that we are so
incredibly vulnerable yeah
well you go in any chimpanzee could
knock your head off
even even you meet a neanderthal they'd
kill us with one punch we are pathetic
but we but our tools allow us to survive
right and our opposable thumbs and our
tools
so it's like we have this superficial
dominance over apex predators because we
drug them and we shoot darts at them and
we put them in cages but the second that
cage unlocks you're like oh yeah right i
remember i had my ear bitten off by a
dog
it's back on they sewed it back on but
the ease with which
it snapped off it wasn't the dog wasn't
even trying to attack me
it was just like a little bite like a
play bite and my entire ear was hanging
off
it happened so quickly and when you sort
of see a part of your body
be able to be removed that you're just
like
we are not durable at all right so
there's one i think there's a pixar
movie or disney movie that
the ant looks at the human is it when
the the boy becomes small
in the ant world oh look mommy his guts
are on the
outside that's what we are we're
pathetic we've got all this soft
stuff that you can just rip off plus
we've got no muscles
this is pathetic you know look at three
years at the gym doesn't really do much
to us
yeah but when i look at people that are
like overly muscular
i'm like you're not reading do you know
what i mean
that's also not great either when you
see someone who's like super muscular
and you're like you have no love in your
life like you're insecure there's a
psychological issue for you know what i
mean that's a whole other addiction i
feel like
this is what humans should look like
thank you we're not going to war
no one's drafting you when i look at
these men in their 40s and 50s that like
need to like i'm just like
what is no one's drafting you
no one's calling you like the patriots
are never going to call you in
why are you spending your life at the
gym this is not a good use of your
time or energy uh no one needs you to be
an adonis
at this age you can run 10 miles great
but you don't have to look like a
cartoon character
you've just again offended a fair number
of people including our friends
i know i think this is important to know
because the men listening i always like
to say there's a there is a lot of
sexism against men which is like
women are always trying to be smaller
and smaller and center and thinner and
men are always trying to be bigger and
bigger and bigger and they live with
anxieties and fear every day
i'm too skinny you know the hairline
thing like men have these very
real insecurities and theirs are ones
that actually you just looked at my
hands you can't really change
i know because you have an incredible
hairline and i remember joe rogan
mentioning that you have no
gray hairs and you still don't we'll
talk about it
but um i think there's something
fascinating about because we don't talk
about male insecurities and male fears
and men's i believe for kraken if i'm
wrong
are height if you're too short hairline
right and dick size three things you
cannot change
women if your insecurities are weight
your skin
your lip those are all chain we can
change those men's are not able to be
changed maybe they're being changed in
your lab right now but
yeah we're working on dick size right
now because
the things that men grapple with with
insecurity
you can't just go to a plastic surgeon
you can't take a vitamin you can't
you know put a hat on you can't put hair
extensions in the way you know what i
mean you can't put the fake nails on
we have this pass where we can kind of
put pieces of plastic on us and no one
thinks it's weird like plastic thick
we can put other people's hair in our
head and people are just fine with it
people think it's pretty can you imagine
and then when guys put a toupee on we're
like
to pay much whereas i'm walking around
with some russian prostitutes hair
in my head at all times like i feel like
uh it's so hard for women yeah totally
but
it is socially acceptable for us to
basically wear
caulk and grout on our face to be able
to sort of hoodwink someone into
thinking we look we can put fake
eyelashes on we can just put spider legs
on our eyelashes and no one thinks it's
weird well that's our ancestors fault
you know we we are descended from people
who women who prided up and
men who were muscular mm-hmm but we're
still pathetic as a species no question
but it's good to maintain some muscle
mass
yes i'm not doing this because i want to
look good um it doesn't hurt but right
i'm doing it because as i get older i'm
losing muscle i'm 51
almost 52. i'm losing about a percent of
my muscle every year
and i don't want to um it's not good for
my health
it's not good for my testosterone levels
which are
helpful in some ways but also what the
biggest problem for the elderly is they
fall over and break their hips
so i exercise to keep those muscles
strong too
so people forget it's not just about
eating less often
it's you gotta do the opposite which is
bulk up as well a bit
i know you're not a big fan of meat
because of the cholesterol and high
protein
my question i have two questions in this
area number one do you ever eat bone
marrow
um i'm not opposed to it yeah do you
have some well i do
i know i was gonna extract some of yours
today for my collection
um no because i i was reading about how
part of the reason
humans were able to grow their brains so
quickly and evolve is because they were
not able to capture
um you know animals they had to
basically eat what was left over
that that apex predators killed right
whether it was like an ox or a moose or
whatever and all that was really left
was the
the bone marrow and and actually that's
the least trash part
of the meat that's where all so that's
how the brains grew so much so actually
not being able to catch the moose
where you would just kind of eat the
meat they had to settle for the crappy
bone marrow
which by some twist of irony was the
most nutritious part
yeah there's some truth to that i i
agree also cooking fire was very helpful
because that unlike what we tend to
think actually cooking
animals is very good for getting the
nutrients out
it's very hard to eat muscle unless it's
cooked and let me ask you
is is part of the reason just as a
expert in genetics and
is the reason that meat is not
particularly good for us is because we
were never able to really capture it
until quite recently and haven't had a
chance to evolve
for it to be healthy for us or to
wow you've asked a question that no one
has
in my circles all right so
thinking on my feet here i think you're
right carnivores don't have a short
lifespan
because they eat meat
i think the reason probably is that we
we haven't been carnivores for that long
but there are other reasons there are
chemical reasons why why meat's not that
good
there are certain amino acids that turn
off our body's defenses
they turn them off so leucine isoleucine
and valine these are called branched
chain amino acids when we eat a lot of
those
there's a defense system called mtor
that
you want to be on and in fact if you if
you make this defense
uh get switched on in a mouse it'll it
can live 20 30
longer so by eating a lot of these amino
acids which is particularly in meat
you're not allowing your body to turn on
defenses as much as it normally would
but by eating mostly plants which is
what i do i
i will eat meat um just not excessively
yeah
you get the benefits the xenohemetic
molecules from from your salad
plus you're not turning off your body's
defenses with
excess amino acids from meat right and
then because if we were designed to eat
meat at every meal wouldn't our
intestines be a little bit shorter
because doesn't the meat tend to putrefy
by the time it gets to our longitude
intestines
oh we have really short intestines
actually for for
a mammal and certainly for a primate
it's shrunk because we were able to cook
our food and get the nutrients out
oh interesting and
the other argument is about how we have
such sharp incisors
but plants are hard to eat too you need
sharp teeth to eat a jicama
what's a jacob it's like a little
a jicama it's a thing that you put in
salad like you know what a watercress is
those little
yummy things g-i-c-i a jicama they have
these in australia
i had a hiccum on my neck
[Laughter]
um if it's from gabby race you better
frame it jicama it's like a
it's like a legume i think that's kind
of crunchy and watery oh you mean a
legume a bit
like um yes and i think that it's not
green so you probably
have deleted it from your memory it has
no use for you
because you don't like starchy white i
try to avoid starch because it's
basically strings of sugar
right but is in and you have said that
basically
the more like exotic or
you know basically the prettiest colored
things are the most stressed out
usually yeah yeah that's like a good
shortcut yeah go for it eat colored
things
right watery white things not so good
because that's usually just like more
sugar and more starch
this is a really crazy question stay
with me
so we know in in these these controlled
environments
in your lab first can i ask just about
the overthinker that i am is it called
the heisenberg effect where what you're
measuring
with affects the outcome is that still
certainty principle
right is that still true and do you
account for that in physics it is
uh yeah actually one of the reasons i
think we'll never be able to fully
download the brain is
that very thing that the act of
measuring it will change it
unfortunately
because you know it's being measured and
you're thinking or something i'm
thinking more
physical of slicing through the brain
and measuring every molecule is going to
change stuff anymore
fascinating uh but yeah why do you ask
that because i'm just i'm just
fascinated in sort of your process and
and and i i your research is correct
like there's a lot of like gut checks of
when like i hear something like that
just doesn't sound right you know even
though i'm not a scientist you know
and i was going to ask you about things
that you feel a hunch about that you
can't prove
right now and i'm just fascinated in
what those are because chances are
you're right if you can't prove it
horses
that um you know famously won't go under
a bridge
and they'll whip it and they'll try to
get it under a bridge and the bridge
will collapse two days later
and there's no way to really explain how
it knew yeah they do have nerve cells
they are
you can't really quantify or
prove something that's that nebulous
and are you saying is there something
i'm not scientific about intangible
no i was gonna ask is there anything and
then i'm gonna get to the mouse thing
but is there anything
that you have a hunch that's true but it
would take 30 years to prove or would
take
10 billion to prove we're like i just i
know this is true
just in my cells does that make sense
uh right how deep do you want to go like
for example like you know there's this
amazing book that i love and i give to
all the women in my life
um by gavin de becker who's a really
famous security person i'm sure you know
him in in
los angeles um and he has a book called
the gift of fear
and it's all about um sort of how when
women
are in these horrible sexual assault
situations by strangers
basically a hundred percent of them the
percent that doesn't
do this is probably just too traumatized
or they weren't really able to interview
them properly
say i knew there was something off about
that guy yeah he carried my groceries he
opened the door for me he was super nice
he was well dressed he had a good job
but i knew there was something off they
can't prove
why there's times i'll have people come
to my shows and there'll be people that
are in like big biker costumes with
chain wallets and securities like are
you worried about that i'm like no not
in the slightest
but then there's someone that seems
non-threatening
or even a woman and you're like i have a
bad feeling and i can't right and dogs
do this all the time
they have this sense like things like
that that you can't really prove
yeah all right so yes there's a bunch
there's a bunch of things um i believe
that we have a backup copy of youth in
all of our cells that can be accessed i
suspect that uh
there is such thing as serendipity
though i cannot prove it
and yes and
if you were going to even try to prove
it where how would you even start
because well you need to have multiple
universes and that's
the problem that's expensive that's
something because you need a placebo
universe
because and i always think about that
because it's like you know when you
you hear a word someone says that shirts
diaphanous and you're like well that's a
big word i never hear and then for some
reason the next book you read it's in it
the next movie you watch diaphanous is
in it and then someone's like that
shirt's diaphragm is you're like i
haven't heard this word in 20 years and
i've heard it three times in a day
yeah did i did i always hear it and i
just never thought about it and now i'm
just looking for it so i've manifested
it like
what there's no way to ignore that
coincidence
right so a layered i guess under that
is um the issue of physics where
you have entanglement that
you know where i'm going i think if you
separate do you know where i'm going
i don't know where you're going but
there are certain places i don't want
you to go
so there are two you separate particles
you split them and then ones
thousand miles away and the other ones
here i mean if you look at that one that
one will change
instantaneously if that isn't
crazy then you're not thinking hard
about it that means there's something
underlying this whole world that we live
in
that we can't even comprehend so i don't
know if that's proof of serendipity
but i've just seen some crazy shit in
serendipity what is that
does that mean something was so
coincidental that it was
planned by a greater force or that you
manifested it or you wanted it so it
occurred
like right because we as humans by
looking at you
you are getting to the uncertainty
principle so just by looking at stuff we
change the universe
that's crazy isn't it crazy does a dog
change the universe when it looks at it
can't prove it i don't know who knows
what about a worm
worms are so cute i'm obsessed with
labyrinth the worm from labyrinth
is my favorite little animal on the
planet i have i'll show you in my attic
i have lots of little statues of her and
um i have a lot of mugs with her on it
too i'm very into the worm from
labyrinth i think worms are important
they are um i'm not going to disagree
they're also very
very good for lifespan experiments
interesting yeah we make them live
longer
benton we take a break to talk
about how we're not only best friends
but
best fiends are we best fiends i feel
like a fiend
i feel like a little bug i'm obsessed
with this listen
i play this game oh my flight was
delayed on the way back from nashville
for like
almost two hours so i'm gonna we're
gonna watch your game for a second
because this is my brain at work because
if you
see how cute this is and how fun this is
to play
also challenging by the way it's not
simple as you look it's a lot of work
you gotta
you gotta get this box down here you
gotta connect doc you only have so many
moves i gotta fight this slug that's
scary
and look at my little creatures those
are little bugs so what are
you're basically you got to match so you
get the little water molecules you got
to get them together
and then that makes my little water bug
shoot some you know i thought
at the slug and then the strawberries
are for the little scorpion dude
the leaves are for that little see a
tick um can i tell you
something about this is so soothing to
me it truly is so
fun there's no other puzzle matching
game like it is so fun they're
always updating it always something new
you're always winning prizes
literally almost every day there's like
some new it feels new
download the five star rated puzzle game
best fiends free today on the app store
or google
play that's friends without the our
best beans this podcast is sponsored by
one of my favorite companies on the
planet it's called brook linen
brook linen it's been a game changer i
used to struggle with sleep i was
insomniac i was too hot i was too cold
the sheets dried out my face i didn't
like it i didn't get a new pillowcase
brooklyn in i sleep like a baby and not
the kind
that scream and pee in the middle and i
and don't sleep well the ones that yeah
baby worth keeping the one you get the
one you give a little benadryl to
a little dying whiskey baby
you i mean listen this is mrs me i'm
having a slumper my little leaf pillow
and my brook linen i couldn't be more
comfortable that's concrete so you can
sleep outside of the concrete and
brooklyn
and the heat still wrapped up look how
happy i am you are still snug
you know that i love the outside when
i'm inside so my brook linen sheets a
fort
everywhere i go i'm comfortably inside
normally when you make a fort with
sheets
it blows away it's not heavy enough it
doesn't protect you from your parents
seeing you this is
the perfect fort sheet oh definitely
isn't that cute
brooklyn it makes it cute also sometimes
i feel really trapped
but but with brook linen i can escape
any situation comfortably and safely
oh really yeah look how easy that is i'm
shimmying right out the window oh my
goodness
i can't always afford a 40-inch custom
lace front wig
but what i can get is my brook linen
wrap myself up and i can turn some loops
look how you just made yourself
into a fashion icon right there and what
is this
that you know what i can royal weddings
debutante balls proms brooklyn and
sheets work they're better than games
this is you just dressed in brooklyn and
sheets
oh i'm on my way to get a snack i gotta
run but i want to be
music video by brooklyn and she's i
don't want to wait for our lives to be
over
this is that tell me it's not that i
want people to understand that brooklyn
isn't just sheets
it's a moment that's a quality sheet
that ripples in the wind like that look
how it just
that sheet made me ten times more
elegant look at this look at the way
that
it it it it um shimmers in the sun
because that is the high quality thread
count
everyone that saw me shocked amazed look
at me i'm a superhero
oh this is a flashback from when i died
as an ex-wife oh this looks
this that is exactly what it is we're
having a flashback i'm so sorry this is
a montage of of a
in an indie movie when they show the
ex-wife in like a nightmare or a dream
look how fun you are look how flirty you
are under there oh what's this
that's that's how it ended oh you're
going to be you want to be buried in
brooklyn and this is that way
they're that comfortable i mean it makes
sense brooklyn does all these other
incredible things as benton just
illustrated with
with these videos i am blown away i am
dazzled i'm impressed and i'm humbled
brooklyn it was started to create
beautiful high quality
home essentials they work directly with
manufacturers
to make luxury available directly to you
without these luxury level
markups thank god you get their
incredible array of products without
having to overpay it's at a reasonable
price because no one should have to
sheets shouldn't be elitist everyone
should be able to get a good night's
sleep
uh they have these like buttery soft
super
breathable sheets they have the plush
absorbent towels that is the only towels
that can clean up the kind of messes i
make
cozy robes and also the the loungewear
is so nice because a lot of loungewear
you feel like it's loungewear and the
knees get baggy and the elastic starts
to pull and you're sort of like
you know it makes you feel like a slob
this is loungewear you could easily
wear to a stumble into a starbucks
they'll be fine with that like it is
quality cozy loungewear they're so
confident in their core products
they'll come with a 365 day warranty
so give yourself the comfort refresh you
deserve and get it for less
at brooklyn and go to brooklyn.com and
use promo code whitney to get 20
off with a minimum purchase of 100
that's brooklyn and
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and enter
promo code whitney for twenty dollars
off with a minimum purchase of one
hundred dollars that's brooklyn.com
promo code whitney
so benton
are you dressed as a ghost you can see
me
yes i can see you you have a gift
what's this video that just appeared
magically on my computer that i didn't
put there or know anything about
let me see it
is that you dress as a ghost i i can't
um
could be but because i'm actually i've
been
being haunted by a very oh shitty
looking ghost lately
i've been haunting you for months so i
ha we were actually had called
security because there was footage on
our security camera
of a ghost cameras can't see ghosts
hold on will you pull up the this is
footage from my ring camera is this you
this is me haunting what you saw
oh i think that was that you said it was
a ghost
with that wasn't you saying you were a
ghost i think that was the ghost of gate
hudson
okay this is the magic of brooklyn and
sheetz
dead or alive they're comfortable
[Applause]
back to our podcast about longevity
which will postpone death
die early stay young forever okay so the
mice
everything that you're proving in mice
horses with the you know reproductive
nature
is there anything that humans because
we're so messy and we're so
um diverse in terms of our trauma our
association to authority or fear of
not being liked i remember when i i
would um when i first
came to los angeles i didn't have any
money and i would do these focus groups
i wrote about this in my book i would do
focus groups for like you can sign up on
this list and they are like hey do you
want to take this pill for two weeks and
tell us how you
did that too really getting 150 bucks
that's cool cash
yes but what i didn't know is you show
up and it's mostly like meth addicts
they don't really want to like improve
the product i was always the
overachiever dork like type a person who
was like
yeah i feel like i you know because
there was one for neutrogena and the
product i don't think ever came out it
came out like
short term and then i think there was
like some weird lawsuit it was like an
exfoliator
and excuse me we had to use it for like
a month and then come in and check in
and talk about it
and i was the person was like you know i
feel like the brush like it goes
counterclockwise it should go clockwise
like i should also chart and everyone's
also like shut up like we're just trying
to get the money to go like get our
methadone
asshole i was like really invested in
making the product better i thought it
was changing the world
and um but i do know that when i would
do some of these experiments i would
very much
tell people what i thought they wanted
to hear and i would go to therapists in
my 20s and lie
because i was just scared that i wa
humans are so complicated we're worried
about disappointing people we're worried
about being embarrassed we're worried
about
um are humans what they say
when you're going to be doing studies on
humans will what they say
ever be valid or does it only have to be
what they're capable of and what their
medical tests are
wow uh well i know a lot about medical
tests i don't know so much about
human humans lie how do you study them
even when they lie to themselves they
might not even know they're lying they
might think they're really healthy they
might come to you and go hey yeah i
don't smoke
so there's a trick in psychology which
is you
bring people in and you tell them this
is what the experiment is but it's not
so they get fooled and then they get
gets revealed what they're really doing
interesting yeah so so because if i came
into your lab
and wanted to be a part of a study on
longevity and you were like okay tell us
about your lifestyle and everything you
do i go
yeah i'm really healthy i only eat
healthy in my head that's what i've
deluded myself into thinking so i don't
feel bad all the time
how can you tell the difference between
someone's delusion of themselves or
narcissism
it's really true yeah yeah and and
number of drinks per week
yeah i'm not a liar remember because i
drink so much i'm gonna say two but it
was five
but i only remember two so what's true
before lunch
so yeah this this is a problem that we
we have very about poor memories and
we're fooled
by by a whole bunch of things
and people want to impress you you're
david sinclair you probably can't even
be in the room like
your presence no i there's this famous
story um
about uh about conan o'brien when he
would go
into the writer's room of a show that he
was producing
they'd be like really creative but when
he came in everyone would be really
intimidated he was here people would
stop pitching and he was like these
writers suck i was like no
they're only like this when you're here
because they're intimidated
right that happens in my lab too so i
try to leave them alone and they're much
more creative and i just judge
what they do later but this is a real
issue that that
when you observe something it changes
so you try to just put things aside and
experiment and we blind ourselves right
everyone knows about double blinds our
experiments
whether they're on worms or mice or
whatever the people who are feeding the
mice
and giving the molecules to mice to make
them live longer we don't know
really which mouse is getting which and
if we look at their organs
the microscopist who's looking at the
organs doesn't know which is which so
that
because otherwise you know oh wow that
one supposed to be young
kind of looks young yeah so we can fool
ourselves it's really terrible
um so that's what we do as scientists
it's all about
trying to make sure we don't fool
ourselves and it's really really hard
it's what we all
it's why we get a phd it's to learn how
to not fool ourselves
and to hold yourself accountable and not
get invested in an outcome
and do i've been working on this for
eight years but
if it's not if the data doesn't say it
i'm not allowed to
yeah you should see what happens
interest in it
yeah yeah there are times that there are
paradigm shifts
in science there's kicking and screaming
when that happens
because people's whole careers are built
on this idea and then it's flipped and
then
then you're in trouble and then there's
a war and then eventually those people
die
and you get you know the new reason the
study becomes about what happens to a
scientist when they go crazy
this is a study just not the study you
thought was happening how quickly could
scientists get themselves fired by being
too invested in evidence
and i guess like i'm i'm fascinated by
the
the intangible things that keep us alive
longer
or less stressed out longer hence alive
whether it's you know a lot of these
places that you know there's always
these articles of who lives the longest
and what
state what country what place it's
usually like a little town in greece or
sardinia
where they boil it down to okay it's the
mediterranean diet
it's the ocean they're looking at the
horizon huberman 101
or they also are a small town where
everyone knows each other
they have eye contact every day they
socialize like the sort of
intangible things and when you look at
like okay do i go work out for three
hours
or do i work out for two hours and
socialize with
one person to get those benefits do i
skip lunch is that better for me or is
having lunch with a friend
where i'm getting that eye contact is
that going to cancel out
the fact that i'm not restricting but do
it all
right exercise with a friend eat a tiny
salad for lunch
i think those are the best combinations
the problem with where we're at in
technology right now knowledge human
knowledge is we know
certain interventions individually
help but what's the best combination we
don't know that we really don't and this
is the problem even in mice we've only
tested one chemical at a time some work
some don't
we've never done two we've certainly
never done three um and it may be a
combination of six that gets us to 120
but who's got the time and money to do
all those experiments right
and then okay so when the mice are
running really fast because they've had
all these longevity
um uh infusions or in nad
and and have stressed out their bodies
and hot and exposure to hot and cold
i this is this is just gonna come i know
this is gonna come off crazy
but the the role when that gets to
humans
and if i'm in your lab and you're in
you've tested you've given me the
vitamin k the vitamin d
the nad the nmn and the resveratrol
for five years and then we're gonna see
if i can run faster on the treadmill
because of all these amazing things i've
been taking and i've been taking care of
myself
and i've been fasting a bit right
trusting my body out and then i get on
that treadmill
and what if i i'm running faster
obviously because of
but what role does fear play in i'm
gonna fucking
beat this person i'm gonna fucking win
this i'm gonna
and then how do you delineate what is
from
the vitamin regimen and what is from the
the will
it's hard this is why we use mice
because they don't
they don't know and we can have they
have nothing to prove
right though uh they we put them on
little treadmills in the lab
so cute yeah they do this buddies you
know it reminds me of did you ever watch
animaniacs pinky in the brain
yes okay that's all i think about uh
yeah they're not as cute as that
but they they do run and and when we
give them this nmn
we have to talk about nad by the way oh
yes please right now
sure okay the reason i can get through
this conversation
for this long and my brain still
functioning is probably because of nad
i've been taking it for about two years
i've been
possibly doing it in ways that you don't
think there's enough scientific evidence
for doing i was doing the
drip so maybe it was placebo effect
who knows but i was feeling a lot of
benefits
from that a lot of people in california
are doing it for people that are
checking into treatment centers
for addiction whether it's i'm getting
these benefits or i
think i'm getting these benefits so now
i feel good i could not tell you
but you've always been like this but do
you feel smarter than usual
i wouldn't go that far smarter and
by smarter you don't mean am i retaining
more knowledge is my
uh processing speed faster that and more
energy through the day
yes yes but the pandemic happened and i
was doing less so i also could have
gotten more energy because i wasn't
running around like a maniac
driving to 10 meetings a day i also was
sleeping more it's like a
i could probably overthink this and i've
cut toxic people out of my life i mean
that's the other thing is like
when people think about healthy living
and putting toxins in that people
you know the healthiest people i know
are in toxic relationships and i'm like
how can you eat this healthy
but let all this unhealthy stuff be in
your brain it's so incongruous to me
you know so it's also simultaneously
when i committed to the nad
because it was expensive i'm doing these
drips i'm also like i'm not going to do
the nad and then hang out with this
asshole
it's going to undo defeats the whole
purpose you know what i'm saying it's
going to cancel
so i also have to do the like um
relationship hygiene of cutting out
people that put
trigger negative chemicals and the
internal drug cabinet in my brain and
age me
like you're aging that's what i think
when i'm looking across at someone
that's like
like you know 40 years old and still
like complaining
that they you know still not haven't
worked on themselves still judging other
people still gossiping
and i'm like you're aging me yeah i i
can't this would be like me
just drinking a giant slushie full of
sugar
talking to you it's true why don't you
use that salad and talking to you it
cancels each other out
yeah that's very smart definitely you
want to do friendship cleansing
um so nad nad is a chemical in our
bodies that we have high levels when
we're young
and you need this chemical for for a lot
of reactions in the body
without it we're dead in 30 seconds or
less um
it's used for making new protein it's
used for your brain activity
and there are defend defensive enzymes
that
clean the body and keep it young and
this is these are the
genes and enzymes that i work on at
harvard called certains the seven of
them
and they need this chemical to work to
defend the body
and if you have high levels of nad and
you're a worm or a mouse
you're protected against diseases and we
haven't published all of this but you
tend to live longer and you you have
greater health right as the animals
but as we get older here's the rub is
that we make less and less of this
molecule and we actually get rid of it
for some reason our bodies degrade it
so by the time you're within without
x-rays and
all the other cellular damage that we do
from living in a modern
right i think it's it's just the natural
natural decline but we can supplement it
and get those levels back up to
being young again so i'm what i said 51
um if you took my skin probably would
have
have half the levels of nad as it did
when i was 20.
that's been published but but no one's
measured my skin but you know what i
mean
the problem there is that that the skin
is now at the whim of
all sorts of damage and you have an
x-ray and you can't fix it you go out in
the sun you get
you get cancer so the idea and this is
bearing out in animals and and we're
doing clinical trials in humans right
now
is that by boosting nad levels the body
acts young again can defend itself again
and maybe even turns back the biological
clock because these sirtuins they
control the epigenome
so remember that the reader of your
genome is just as important
and these are two and defense enzymes
read the genome and make sure that the
body
stays younger what is the
ideal milligram of nad
a day in a pill form and why don't you
have a brand of
because when you talk about this i know
maybe there's like an
ethic something i don't know but our
scientists are you allowed to have your
own line of this because
when i hear you talk about this and then
i go to amazon i'm like i don't know
what brand to get i want his brand
i want one that he his name's on
yeah well harvard frowns on that so that
what i'm okay
i don't wanna get okay they also frown
on
inclusive comedy and they also frown on
being nice to women when they run tv
shows in hollywood
all right well well i once was part of a
supplement company when i was in my 30s
and they said
if you keep doing this you will no
longer be here and people who do what
you're doing are no longer with us they
said
why don't you get so rich and i'll
donate it back and buy you a freaking
building don't all you want us to do is
donate to the place that we already paid
to go to
there's another reason not to do it oh
and that is that i can speak as a
scientist and have no conflict with no
invested interest that's exactly right
but i'm doing something i think is
even better but to me i already trust
you and i just want to take what you
give me it's you're doing you i'm not
losing my trust in you just because
you're
making money off things that you
freaking discovered well maybe so
so what i want to do is why does some
huckster with a pyramid scheme get to
make all the money
well there are some professors who are
selling nad stuff and
i don't trust them as much but so what i
want to have to buy my nad from a
multi-level marketing scheme can you
please just make it
well we've made it and it's in clinical
trials it'll eventually if it works
become a drug that your doctor will give
you
for a variety of elements maybe one day
aging which i hope will be a disease
that
your doctor can treat for you uh but
what i'm doing is
is i think even more important which is
building a company that will measure
your age and then
recommend things that i vet to be
safe pure and actually proven to work
and so we'd be the hub and then you can
trust me that way
and won't that and i'm happy to run this
leg of your company
won't that establishment
also have to have a psychiatric element
that's like you have to take all these
supplements and you need to get a
divorce
you know like is there gonna have to be
a and you can't talk to that friend
anymore because on your heart monitor
every time you hang out with that person
your heart rate goes up that person is
making like will that have to be a part
of your
it will be now that's a great idea
what's the point of taking all these
supplements if you're hanging out with
that guy that
texts you once a week and just confuses
you with an eggplant emoji every night
like
how is it you know like you're the the
the neurochemicals you're producing
around this person are also aging you so
we need to cut that person out also
i love it right i'll run that i'll run
the intervention side because
there are a lot of things that you know
i'm sure these these drive you nuts but
um uh uh maybe i don't know maybe this
is an
aphorism or a platitude but that married
people live longer
in general depends on who you're married
to that's what i'm saying
yeah that's what i'm saying so it's like
that feels like a very tricky
and i'm sure with the logic behind it is
like if you're a man that is in
you're gonna live longer because you're
gonna take less risks you're gonna ride
less motorcycles
you know maybe it's more that or you
have kids so you're
just more i don't think kids make you
live longer it doesn't feel like they
make you
take less risks you're like i guess i
can't go have that fifth drinking or
that strip club because freaking
my kids at home like doesn't it sort of
the same way that that
dogs are so healthy for you and animals
are so healthy dogs
in particular because they also help you
routinize your life
you have to get up at a certain time you
have to get home at a certain time you
can't stay out til four in the morning
if you have a dog at least if you're
treating inhumanely so
yes all the oxytocin you're getting from
snuggling with the dog is important
but also the way you routinize your life
more right and there's also when you get
old
you have someone who'll take care of you
that's a big deal so i would say
get married at 65 70 that's a good age
and someone younger than you yeah make
sure they're young and healthy
because that that'll be their burden but
yeah i think marriage is
it's got to be the right person
otherwise it's really bad and it's
actually been proven
that companionship is one of the leading
predictors of longevity but it doesn't
have to be someone you're married to
if you have good friends that is what is
the greatest thing in life
um and that that's a harvard study so i
think you might be able to trust that
one
and is in that study oh yeah harvard
people who are known for being great
friends
um there is a big sort of stigma
slash uh putting a glorification of
uh hollywood writers that are from
harvard
because uh the writers that come out of
harvard at least in the last like
10 years like these they are just so
smart
and they're so they come out to
hollywood and now all of a sudden
they're they went from harvard to
hanging out with
like people that were just the hottest
person in their hometown so they moved
here and then they just they think
they're so
smart just because they're the smartest
person in a room of actors that just
came here because they were pretty and
you're like okay
you're dumb in boston you're smart
because you're in hollywood like don't
get this ego that you're the smartest
person on the planet just because you're
smarter than these five
models i'm saying yeah well i work there
every day
there's some really smart people there
actually just in my department i think
there's three nobel prize winners
i know people are coming out of your
department and coming and write on the
simpsons
no that's for sure people like i went to
harvard and i write a cartoon
i'm smarter than all of you he's like
okay you write a cartoon child let's
just
let's you write fart jokes let's just be
easy like i'm sick of being shamed by
people in hollywood that went to harvard
i went to penn it's a pretty
good school but we don't we have shame
and we have low self-esteem
so you've got to have arrogance at
harvard to survive
interesting yeah what
i don't know it's an uncomfortable
silence i love uncomfortable silences
because you're so measured in the way
you talk like i'm fascinated by you you
will not
say any more than you need to say and if
something's in yes or no
there's so few people in my life or my
world that will just go yeah
no it makes for a terrible podcast right
no but it's just fascinating to me
because the answer is either yes or no
you're a scientist there's no gray area
it's yes or no whereas i'm like yeah
because they're also look it could be
true
like i can argue not two sides of the
same i i
contradict myself every other sentence i
say but you're just like no the answer's
no
well it has to be because our my whole
career our career as a scientist
are people constantly calling bullshit
on you so you
you have to just make sure that you're
always speaking the truth every month is
that dynamic because it's it's
the smartest people in the world you're
in such
rare company and the only people that
can really relate to you or understand
you
or maybe make you feel less alone are
these people that think like you but
they're also
in a way your adversaries or referees
they make me feel alone
all the time really uh that they are
adversaries there's there's a lot of
competition
how come they've got a nobel prize and i
don't that's not fair are nobel prizes
like oscars where they're kind of just
bought
or are they really earned they're
definitely earned they definitely earn
but um but you're not allowed to talk
about it
if you say so-and-so should get a nobel
prize or oh you know maybe my my latest
work is worth nobel prize
that's really bad you don't talk about
it you have to
do amazing amazing work but not think
it's amazing of course
yeah okay um this is perfect for an
australian got it
you know how to do that we do but but
it's real that's really
i don't think i'm that smart i just do
what i think is fun
but in my department it's really scary
i've got the imposter syndrome there
because i'm sitting around tables with
people who are famous
and change the world and i'm thinking
yeah
but you're at that table well i am
thinking about you i think i belong
there
but that's part of why you're so good is
that you doesn't
a little imposter syndrome go a long way
in terms of not being an imposter
because you work so hard that you'll
never be one if you fear being one
the true that's why i do try so hard
because i want to be accepted
like like you said yes the only reason
that i got
learned of vocabulary other than the
fact that i kind of knew i was going to
talk for a living
is i was so insecure that i wasn't smart
that i would just study dictionaries
when i was like yeah you have
an amazing vocabulary thank you i
noticed thank you
i can't pronounce half the words in this
book and i've delicately tiptoed around
them with
prosaic words but um i'm going to do a
little speed round with you
and then i know i have to let you go
because you have to go save the world
and i feel guilty when i'm keeping
people like you here
like i'm stopping progress of like
humanity if i
keep you in my house too much and then i
also want to talk about some of the
businesses you're starting
um your friend that you brought today is
named whitney
so she is she brought me she writes she
did
she um uh whitney casey i want to talk
about the business you're starting
and um how valuable real scientists are
in like businesses moving forward and
what's that like because
you know i find even sometimes when i'm
the most well intentioned in some
business things there's certain things
that
i just don't know you know power or
corporations when things become
commodified there's always going to be a
little undertone of evil and how do we
fight that like
for example i invested in lime scooters
i'm like this is great people aren't
going to have to have
have cars and it's it's not elitist
transportation isn't elitist anymore and
anyone can grab it
emergency room visits in la went up 60
percent
oh no like this benevolent
instinct like i was like oh no no i'm
like helping people just like
break their necks all day you know it's
just sort of this double-edged sword of
when you're taking a
benevolent cause into business and the
very real
you know emotional costs of it or the
the things you just have to settle with
of going
like you know for me i just invested in
the company that i was like i don't know
if this is ethically
a sound company but if i didn't
take this piece of the pie someone would
someone who's a bad person maybe a good
person should take it because what i'm
going to use with the money is actually
going to be
beneficial to because i can donate the
money whereas some
psychopath wouldn't and they would just
keep it to build their
you know eugenics program at debutante
balls across
whatever exactly that's the reason to
make money because you you will spend it
wisely
right so a lot of i think the best
people the most ethical people like no i
don't want to capitalize on this or no i
don't want to cash out on this that
feels wrong you're the exact person that
probably should it's like all the people
that want to run for
president i don't think should ever run
anyone that wants to run
is inherently disqualified you know i
think they should just go
up to like a good person one day who
like runs a car dealership you're like
you're the president it should be like
oh shit i don't want to do that and
they'd probably be the best
right probably the same in marriage just
random is probably better than people
you're attracted to that's really funny
i mean
if you have not done work on yourself
right because for me
i remember going to my uh therapist who
i think you would love she's very
um you know into you know attachment
strategies and like inherited fears and
you know nothing's your fault that's
irrational
addiction how it's to switch your bad
addictions to good addictions don't over
pathologize yourself with addictions
just
choose a healthy addiction you know
reroute those are actually all of the
things we pathologize and
perceived you know by society weaknesses
and character flaws are actually
superpowers they're just
you've directed the energy in the wrong
place your porn addiction turn that into
writing that book
how to reroute that energy and retrain
your brain i'll consider it
and um where am i going with that oh is
that the people
i remember going to um uh her once when
i was in in my 20s and i had just gotten
out of a really toxic bad relationship
i had been in a lot of bad relationships
it's his fault it's his fault the common
denominator
was me in all of them and
i went up to her and i had found someone
that was in my field
but adjacent to me so i wasn't going to
emasculate them or i wasn't there wasn't
going to be some weird power imbalance
or uncomfortable
um jealousies or anything and i went up
to and i was like this is who i think
this is who i'm gonna date next he does
charity work and he does this
and he's this and he's been divorced he
has a kid so he's calmed down and he has
less testosterone and this is perfect
i had it all figured out and she just
looks and she goes you can't date him
and i was like why do you know something
about him what is that no he's like the
perfect guy and she's like
you cannot date this person i was like
why and she goes
because you're attracted to him wow if
you're attracted to someone that's a red
flag oh come on
well at the time i was recreating my
childhood circumstances and i was
magnetically attracted to people that
created chaos made me insecure
made me uh sort of feel that warm hug of
dysfunction
and drama i could walk into a room and
within 20 minutes
be talking to the most damaged sick
manipulative
dishonest sociopathic person and like be
in love we call them christmas trees
like i'm just like they just light up
for us
and because boredom i
i you know she finally explained to me
what is boring to you is actually just
serenity
so if you're bored in a relationship
it's probably just healthy got it
well no no disrespect you to your
relationship but why did you say you
want men with lower testosterone
at the time i was just looking for
excuses for why it wasn't my fault
and i was looking for everyone else
needed to fix themselves
because i was perfect right which is
whatever my ego had to
develop in my childhood when um primary
caretakers were not perfect and there
was a lot of mental illness around the
only way to stay safe was don't cause
any problems be perfect be a straight a
student this is going to minimize any
backlash
or discomfort or punishment i can't
outshine anyone but i also need to be
perfect
like like that people-pleasing of like
shape-shifting for narcissist
and and mentally ill people so that i
was in less dangerous so why
testosterone
aggression because i think in my head i
was like if a guy has too much
testosterone he's going to cheat he's
going to get on motorcycles
he's going to have to chase strange what
do the kids call
it these days he's going to be a
philanderer he's going to
you know test i had this thing in my
head that was like too much testosterone
is
bad and it was also at a time that i was
on a birth control
that i talked about this in my third
special about um there was a study that
came out that said
women that are on certain birth controls
because they smell
pheromones differently because birth
control basically makes your body think
it's pregnant right so you're
essentially when you're on birth control
you're pregnant for all intensive
purposes and we're attracted
to men that are more quote alpha
risk takers when we're on birth control
because it's our body's way of saying
i'm vulnerable i'm about to have a child
to protect i need the strongest biggest
most tattooed
guy that wears axe body spray instead of
you know the dork who's actually
probably going to be the better husband
so they say
go off if you get engaged to someone
don't marry them until you've gone off
birth control for a year to make sure
you're still attracted got it so when
i'm going to pick up a woman i ask you
on birth control
that'll cut cut to the chase and if they
are just like all right i rode my
motorcycle
pull out your chair brass knuckles you
know so just sort of those like
it changes something with your old
factory glands or something but i'm just
fascinated by
uh you know what we're attracted to is
not always good for us emotionally we're
physically i want to have pizza every
day that doesn't mean i can
right that's the thing i'm most
attracted to but chances are i probably
should just have that kale salad
even though it's not what i want to have
the affair with
right you just summarized everything
that i believe in which is that
what makes us gives us pleasure isn't
always what's good for us
but it's that served us one because i
think it's important to be able to
something we do in 12-step programs is
if you have negative
instincts or fears you anthropomorphize
them and you kind of make them
sort of uh um you basically turn them
into
you can turn them into a character you
can name your shadow there's lots of
different ways of doing it
uh but you go so if i meet a
new friend a potential new girlfriend
whitney casey over here
i have so much in my hippocampus is so
chock-full of negative relationships
with women i grew up around a lot of
mental illness
borderline personality disorder women
that had very big emotions a lot of them
justifiably so
you know having to work and care for
kids and be overwhelmed in the sexist
environment and all the stresses they
were under
and so women just always to me when i
was in female friendships it was a i was
attracted to women that were very
mercurial
and needed to be rescued where i would
sort of caretake them in a maternal way
and i would
sort of check out of my own life by
obsessing over
their drama and it was ultimately
patronizing to them because i'm like
this grown woman needs me to take care
of her that's so narcissistic and such a
god complex thing
but i always sort of for women i
couldn't let them too far in because i
always felt like they would hurt me
because they were irrational and they
were
emotional and deeply on some level
jealous and i couldn't outshine them and
i had to minimize myself so hang out
with women
because of the women that i was around
when i was a child i thought all women
were dangerous emotionally and that you
had to make yourself small you had to
shape shift
you had to not be too pretty but you had
to be funny but not funnier than them
and
it was exhausting to me but that was all
shit i was
doing and where are we go where am i
going with that you know
well i know that that you like taking
care of people and animals
and that makes you a good person yeah
but sometimes when we care to take other
people it's selfish and it's for our own
ego it depends on what our motives are
like this is what we're going to get
into when i have my little
kiosk at your longevity lab that where
i'm going to tell people to get out of
bad marriages and cut off
toxic people no you don't have to go to
that baby shower you do not have to if
anything's out of obligation you do not
have to do it
well we're going into business you
already have figured out what we're
gonna do
yeah no i'm gonna i'm gonna be um like
the
life coach in the corner that tells
people to get out of bad marriages
no you don't have to talk to that person
if they if they were late three times
you're done they don't respect your time
there's no conversation you don't stay
in this relationship and just get mad
and because resentment ages us right
when we drink poison and
wait for the other person to die you
know when we're angry at people when we
you know what do you make of like this
addiction to self-righteous indignation
on the internet now like this is one of
the things that is gonna like mess up
the bell curve in terms of combating
longevity is the fact that people are
going on the internet and just
raging exactly exactly so that this is
again what i'm writing about
in this new book is that the world will
be built look it is
killing us after we go into business
together
the the three of us this new company by
the way do you know steve jobs you know
that um you do have you heard of him
i just mean remember the steve jobs
movie i don't know if this happened in
real life or not but remember in the
movie he had two assistants named billy
and he's like billy
you're jim like he just had to change
the person's name because he didn't have
time to
for confusion well you both have the
same initials which is
a bit confusing that's so wide what's
your middle name whitney casey
brooke okay that's right whitney brooke
casey mine's a
and w-a-c whack it's weird
so how do you choose your time is so
valuable even though you're going to
live to be 200 so maybe
you know there's not the same scarcity
accomplished with you how do you choose
what business says
to start and which ones to not and how
to use your time
no one's ever asked me that thank you um
i let me think
so highest impact on the planet so the
reason i exist the reason i want to
exist
uh is to leave the world a better place
i know that sounds sick but that's what
i wanted to do was it like that before
you had kids
it it was even stronger before i had
kids
you're like no now i made these really
smart kids they can solve it
yeah my work's done right i know
seriously when i was four i
i was told that i have to make the world
a better place this is my grandmother's
influence
and so i do that every day i've gotten
up this has been my goal and so i pick
businesses
based on solving problems and then
figure out how to do that
okay and what whitney and i and you
are going to do is to help people figure
out how to be well
in a scientific way not just go on to
online and hope for the best that that
supplement
is actually what they say it is or that
that gym equipment actually works or
this
or a ring is going to help you that's
what i want to do is to put science into
wellness
in a way that people can have
proof in their own lives that what
they're doing is working or to be
hold themselves accountable in a way
that they can't be delusional about it
yeah it's both it's both i want people
to be we want people to be cognizant of
the
of the fact that they can change their
lifespan
and their health but also give them
feedback we can now
with technology out of my lab that can
tell you
how you're doing in terms of your age
your biological age we can measure that
quickly and cheaply just a mouth swab
but also other things
future fertility skin these kind of
things we're going to add to that
and when when you get feedback then you
really think about it otherwise you just
go oh whatever i don't care when i'm 60
but if you can see
when you're going to die you pay more
attention to it there's going to be some
kind of
like insurance break if you're on the
sinclair casey
thing right there's going to be some
kind of because humans write in order to
be motivated they either have to have
super negative consequences or something
like
really positive like a like a financial
if it's like you pay
a thousand dollars less a year in your
insurance if you're on the
sinclair kc don't give away all our
secrets okay sorry
like i just see it i see that so clearly
i see you see
it's like a good driving record yes and
people will know because all the
algorithm they're looking at all our
data anyway they're looking your amazon
purchases and adjusting your insurance
accordingly so they're gonna well if you
have a bad result and you're 10 years
older you don't have to show it to
anybody but if you're
if you're younger by all means you got a
ticket do you ever have time to read
fiction
occasionally there's this you're like a
lot of scientists a lot of scientists
put out fiction what do you mean
that's how competitive you guys are yeah
i just read a couple studies from
stanford that read like fiction
yeah the worst are from stanford really
really stanford's
human ring yeah
you know been on the podcast will be on
the podcast again i remember one day
like
like taking his advice so uh
seriously that i forgot to use common
sense like you know he has this thing
that's like go out in the morning and
look into the
sun and look at horizons and i like went
outside like before my car and i just
really get a headache and i was like
okay don't stare in the sun that cannot
be what a
brilliant scientist is telling me to do
let me re-watch that video
anyways close your eyes and look at it
don't look i was like looking directly
into eclipse like this can't be
this is the latest science i guess is
good stressing out my body stressing out
my obstacle
this is regenerating my eyes right now
you know so there are times when like
i will just you know people like me
dumb idiots like me can take science and
like still hurt ourselves with it if we
don't really understand
like and you starting this business
clearly seems like it's bridging between
this sort of science you would
need a degree to understand in putting
it in a way that's accessible
to the i don't want to say average
person but the person who doesn't have a
doctorate
exactly well so i'm the science brain
and whitney over here
is the rest of it which is how to make
things simple
and easy for people um that makes sense
because i'm going to make it too
complicated
but whitney's built companies for
consumers before so it's a it's a good
match
fascinating okay i'm going to do a
really quick speed round
uh some people have sent questions that
we know very well jennifer anderson and
sandra bullock have questions and i have
got to answer them
they are listening sorry gals i'm just
getting into it now
metformin you are on you take it at
uh no i don't take it at night i
take it how dare you disagree with me in
front of the
morning oh i thought you took it at
night well i maybe i used to
but i found that it just sits in my
stomach and causes pain yeah
i'm quite sensitive to it it hurts my
stomach how many milligrams do you take
uh i take depends on the day and whether
i'm working out but
a gram one which is a low dose i mean a
diabetic will take two grams okay
okay for those of you don't know
metformin's a diabetes drug
and you need a doctor to get it that
manages your glucose levels
therefore um helping
fight against cancer and aging yeah
something like that
it brings down the sugar levels but also
it's been found just by looking at tens
of thousands of people who have taken it
that they're healthier than people that
don't have type 2 diabetes
so it seems to be a magical so many
people in hollywood take it i do know
that oh do they yeah
along with drinking the baby blood you
know they go they sell them at the same
time i don't think you just drink the
baby blood
okay i don't know but i've heard i i did
i did
joe rogan's podcast like whatever it was
like a couple weeks ago
and i don't know what he says something
about my my skin or something he's like
you look healthy i was like yeah it's
all the baby blood that i'm eating like
the q
on conspiracy right like joking about it
i had just um
watched the q a on documentary and then
the rabbit hole is a podcast uh new york
times podcast that's sort of about
how people get sucked into q anon and
and i'm always obsessed with how humans
sort of are
uh predisposed to be conned or on some
level participate in being conned
because they feel like they're a part of
something just how vulnerable we are to
bullshit
is fascinating to me um and then john
bojar is my favorite philosopher and how
you know
things that are real have been
duplicated and artificial so many times
by the time we see the real thing we
think it's fake
you know that's like i was just in
sedona in arizona and i got there and i
was like this looks like the screen
saver on my
it's prettier on my screen saver like
when you see the real thing right
it's actually not even as impressive and
it's less hot when it's on the computer
yes exactly and you're just kind of like
oh this is hot and sticky i used to be
able to watch this just like i saw this
beautiful view like in my
office you're putting hoodies on yeah
exactly and i was like
and also um just kind of the the
our art of so much of in our life is
artificial to the point to where i
remember
the first time i had grapes as a like
kid i had already had like
grape runts and grape bubblicious gum
and grape gum is so much better than
grapes by the time you have real
grapeshot
what is this trash yeah you know grapes
will do to you it'll spike your blood
sugar
massively i found out but we like the
resveratrol
that comes from the skin uh yeah we
found years ago that it made fat mice as
healthy as the thin mice and they live
just as long as the thin mice so it's
like mimicking being skinny without
having to watch what you eat
interesting so you're not eating grapes
you're not popping grapes you're not
no i stopped eating grapes a few years
ago because i had
you know you can monitor your blood
sugar you you can put a little
thing on i don't know you're just
covered in devices you're like ex
machina
yes okay i do know that i believe in
science okay so i put that on my arm
okay
and i could see when i ate something
what my sugar levels were over the next
few hours
and grapes were the worst yeah but what
if you're on metformin and eating grapes
like here's my thing it's a lot of times
when i f it's like i'm like whack-a-mole
the way my brain wants to
manipulate around so i go if i'm taking
metformin
i can have this piece of cake whereas if
i wasn't on metformin i wouldn't eat the
cake
so sometimes humans when we do something
healthy like supplements we're like well
i'm taking a supplement so i can eat
this other trash yeah
yeah and you can eat it um i don't know
about that but the occasional cake's not
going to kill you right right i just
mean like the way that our brains go i'm
doing this healthy thing to justify that
yes yeah like oh it cancels it out the
the lies we tell ourselves in order to
right i'll take an nad fusion infusion
and i'll smoke
yeah yeah while i'm doing it so it's not
true
this is really important you're
listening yes okay
if you take a healthy mouse and give it
what we are talking about
resveratrol or some of these other
things they get even fitter and stronger
and live longer
so it's not an excuse to sit on the
couch and watch movies just if you take
something that
i'm taking but i think that's an
important thing to talk about people
because i think you know when i first
hear this information from a
forward-facing scientist and then like
oh i'm doing all this healthy stuff now
i can go
do all this other unhealthy stuff you
know it's not permission
to behave like a dickhead to yourself
right
right you want to maximize it so that's
why i do everything that i can
and this company is going to help people
realize like just because you did this
doesn't mean you have extra credit
points in some arsenal where you get to
act like a shithead and do dumb shit and
i take resveratrol so i don't have to
wear sunscreen like
just the way that our non-scientific our
emotional brains
give us fake permission exactly and this
will tell you if you're doing a good job
or not
and when we've done millions of people
will know are those people that do
those things are the ones that age
backwards or slower
and also knowing how long you're in the
sun like you know there are times like i
never got in the sound you're like but
did you drive for 45 minutes today
did you like there's times that you
don't count
that bad things are happening or they're
exposed to things because you just don't
know to count it
i had horrible sun damage on my hand
i when i was uh because i would drive to
and from school every day
high school and there was a sun roof
that would go right onto my hands every
day and i just didn't think about you
don't put sunscreen on your hands no one
told me to do that you put on your face
right this was also a time when i was
going to tanning beds three times a day
so there was
i know but i looked cute i was so
hot though um i was just like uh
just a caramel queen of bethesda
and then i come out to la i've never
been in california i come out to do some
like ucla theater program
i got in the sun put sunscreen
everywhere except my hands and then i
started getting these giant
blisters i went into ucla the emergency
room
and i i didn't really understand the
concept of like a teaching
hospital because it was at a university
and the the doctor
came in and like was like and then
started calling in other students and
they started taking photos of it to like
put in a textbook i was like this can't
i guess is my first big publication i'm
in i'm on the cover
like but just sort of i didn't realize
like i would need a device to tell me
hey
dumbass you think you've only been in
the sun for 10 minutes today to get your
dose of vitamin d but you also walked
the dog
you drove sun comes through glass dummy
thank you that that's the future um
where's that little device
so this thing that's stuck in my chest
please don't do that
we don't need to look inside you yet but
this device
combined with what we're doing in our
new company
perhaps one day it'll be the same
company is that it'll be able to tell
you
everything about your body how you're
doing your age
your fertility your sex drive but also
hopefully
how to fix it all and combined with
these things it'll also be able to tell
you
uh where you are which restaurant to go
to which is the best food if you want to
try it
all right if you've been out in the sun
watch out there's a restaurant to start
buying that
is that going to be corrupted this is
where good intentions go sideways like
what if
the restaurant's like i'll give you a
million dollars if you suggest my
restaurant
well that's okay as long as we get 40
[Laughter]
like is that gonna start happening it
might right vouchers for health why not
it'll be like take left at a burger king
and i'm like how about you that was
definitely paid for health insurance
we'll pay for it
good point as long as you eat the right
meal good point
and then okay this is a speed round i
know i have to let you go do liquid
aminos work
sure that you put on your salad or what
general vibrancy well yeah i'm
as long as they're not full of those uh
leucine valine isoleucine branch chain
amino acids you're good
but yeah quick absorption yeah like
would you ever put that on your salad
like dr bragg's liquid aminos
no no no because i believe if you eat a
healthy balanced
salad it's got enough you don't need
those if you're adding stuff you're
probably not
eating well to begin with uh i wouldn't
say that but i would say amino acids are
very hard to be deficient in
hmm oh got it okay so that's a scam got
it
um let me ask you about protein-rich
plasma topically on the skin is that
real
well uh so there are peptides that seem
to boost
the skin's thickness that are topical or
that are injectable
um i certainly know about the topical
experiments
um and i'm just trying one out right now
that was sent to me the signs looked
good
i think it's working can you put it on
your skin every day
uh yeah for the last month or so two
months okay
um so i'd like to experiment those what
that way but i should really do half my
face that would
i used to do that for qvc i used to do
um like home shopping network stuff and
they would put
self tanner on one side of my face and
not the other to show the difference and
then i was in like
half black face like walking around
philadelphia's nightmare i didn't want
to show up on on your podcast with half
an
ugly face oh we'll put it in a post
don't worry um
so uh emfs
the idea that phones have radiation you
say you don't fly a lot on planes
emily was around when i used to wear i
would wear
a suit on a plane that was supposed to
block emfs
i actually was like in talks with under
armour about because i was trying to
figure out what blocks emfs and how to
apply that
to baby clothes and to like cribs and
paint
because so many people live near cell
phone towers and so many people live
near whatever like how to
you know and remember we were powering
off all our devices in the home
i was told that these emfs from our cell
phones and cell phone towers
our body can regenerate from it but it
just never has a break
were you told by a real scientist this
was a psychic that worked out of her
home in venice i paid her by check how
dare you
emily says no i have no i have no idea
so i'm just you say you don't fly is
that
is is cell phone radiation that does i'm
not worried about cell phones not word
at all no
i've looked into it there's no evidence
great
but flying is a different type of
radiation it's coming from the sun it's
strips your dna it hits the plane or
only if your window's open
do you open the windows
i mean if you're the thing's up and the
sun's coming i know that
no these things pass straight almost
through lead
it's hard to stop them so the more we
fly the more our dna is being damaged
yeah and try going to mars
and not getting cancer that's a problem
so we work on that as a problem too
because elon doesn't yet think it's a
big problem it's not worried about
getting cancer
he should be right but the kind of
person
is is that like part of the reason why
michael phelps uh
you know was such a good swimmer is he
had some kind of defect that made his
heart bigger
and his body like perfectly designed to
swim a certain way
tiger woods or whatever his gift was
lance armstrong whatever his
and part of the gifts of these people
like elon is like a brain miswiring that
makes him not afraid of doing something
most people should be afraid of which is
why would amelia earhart have gotten in
that fucking plane that was so
she must have had some kind of you know
amygdala deformity that made her not
scared of that
sure but that's no excuse for stupidity
yeah no no offense elon
i'm a big fan but do we need his sort of
blind spot and whatever the arrogance is
that says i'm not going to get this
despite the science is that the kind of
person you need in order to forge ahead
for something like space
travel yes i mean there's a huge risk
that people will take but it's a risk
that you don't have to take
you could boost the body's defenses
against these
cosmic rays gamma rays and other things
um
and so it's one of the things we worked
on with nasa we we won some
nasa award for not just shielding the
spacecraft well you've won so many
awards it's like it's somewhat word
it's somewhere in my basement well i
didn't even know why i said that
but what we're saying is instead of
shielding the spacecraft which would
take a meter
of water which you'd know is three feet
you can actually take a pill and protect
the dna from the inside
so that's a simple solution won't take
the pill yeah he will
we'll see i'll ask him he will take it
why not there's nothing to lose it's
we've tested these molecules in
hundreds of people now so there's
nothing there's a certain recklessness
and abandon that's needed to be one of
these elite people right like the fact
that you were like i'm gonna change the
world
like most people would say that and they
would be delusional like people that you
would put an insane asylum if they said
something like that
like what's the difference between
someone that just says that and there's
a crazy person on the street that you
would cross the street if they say i'm
gonna change the world you'd be like oh
that person's crazy
you said it's not much of a difference
actually you've said it
and the only reason you're not like a
scary schizophrenic person is because
you actually did it
well i figured out how to do it starting
with the goal in mind and then i had to
be good at science i had to get a phd i
had to go to mit to get experience in
aging research
it's all been part of an execution plan
so i'm crazy you have to be equal at
least i plan
crazy and reckless but also strategic
and disciplined it's that that per
that's why people like you are so rare
because it's so odd to have that
combination
yeah and and you have to be scientific
and creative at the same time which i
would say
elon has that and uh
is uh gut bacteria is this a big thing
on your
list whose question is this this is i've
got i've got questions from very famous
people
i'm not gonna embarrass them by saying
which questions are from which people
but there's a lot of
probiotics and and i drink kombucha and
i
i think i feel better when i drink it
and have
billions of bacteria good gut bacteria
but are
is this something that's a priority in
your life if not i'm gonna just throw it
all out
uh no there's some good science behind
it the microbiome is very important
and it changes as we get older and it's
been shown at least in fish
i think in mice too that if you put
young back
young mouse bacteria into an old mouse
certainly in a fish
they live longer so the science isn't
really there for humans yet right we're
not eating young people's
feces a lot of people on reddit think we
are
in hollywood on epstein's plane
and a lot of people would argue with you
on that yeah so i i think microbiome
and and some of the the replacement
makes sense scientifically i haven't
seen a lot of studies that say
it changes your life yet but probiotics
there's some science behind it
i wouldn't throw it out put it that way
two famous actresses
who are known for their perfect skin and
bodies have some questions
um thoughts on peptides injectable
peptides i
am on them and i'm 76.
we have to measure your age with this
new test and then we'll know
oh god uh no one will believe that i'm
38. the irony is i'm 38 i'm just like
i'll buy it that's right we'll change
your name
just in case so what um so peptides yes
do you do them no why not uh well i put
that that cream has a peptide in it so
that's my first foray into it
uh so i've called up friends to ask who
know this stuff
um i even talked to andrew i know andrew
huberman i sent mine to him
the ones that i'm taking and i
am on i uh
uh hold on i'm just
looking through our samarellan sir
marilyn
and i do one at night
and one in the morning okay
so the answer is maybe okay but they
haven't been studied enough
see that's someone like me or maybe as a
yes this guy might be interested in me
i'll turn that i'll turn him maybe into
a yes any day
i made a career out of it well that
that's fine you know
a lot of the stuff that i take isn't
proven to work either there's just a lot
of evidence
right um but if we wait another 30 years
oh that's too late because my question
is like not only do peptides work for us
but can i put them in my dogs
oh even less evidence but but even more
important you don't want to experiment
on no best friends no no no it's better
if if you
end up with problems right yeah no i
would trust me i agree
uh uh thoughts on
bio photo modulation
light therapy oh that's interesting too
uh yes whoever's listening the famous
a-list actress you know you asked that
and i didn't so don't give me the credit
for being an interesting question
all right so the expansion on that is
that i've seen some good evidence that
it can help with hair growth
so that you can get these i really do
want to grow my pubes back i lasered
them off in my 20s and it's i miss them
now
but what about infrared light saunas
would you do that
or do you um i probably would do it it
would feel good
mm-hmm at the very least like a
cryotherapy which i did with
joe rogan that that made me feel
promised like the amount of time like
it's a full-time job by the time you get
in the sauna and then you get in the
cold plunge and then you get the light
therapy
and then you know i mean it's like what
do we prioritize if we could bring a
friend you eat a salad you read a book
do it all so the light therapy i think
there's some so there's
infrared deep infrared near-infrared it
can penetrate the skin
um and i think it's changing the uh the
epigenome
mm-hmm um that hair study makes me
believe that stem cells in your head
might
get reactivated so it's plausible a lot
of people were injecting prp
in needles of their own prp into bald
spots
i don't know if it was working or not i
i've seen that it does help yeah and
i've read all these
these studies and uh so that makes sense
there are peptides and all sorts of
things in prp
it'd be better if we knew what worked
and we just put those on our heads
right but then it's also the idea of
like you're doing all this stuff
but this is part of what your company i
i assume is gonna do which is like
yes you're doing all this infrared light
but you're also not eating this or
taking this so there's no point in doing
this
if you're not in conjunction with these
other two things exactly nothing is like
an isolated
you know panacea for something yeah
that's exactly right and and right now
as you have just said we have no idea
what works for us
and we're all different how do we know
that eating that or doing that or
shining that
is good for us because we're all
different we have different gut
microbiomes
of course a lot different genes
different epigenomes even twins are
different
twins have different lifespans identical
twins because they live differently
benton ate his twin in the womb i think
so that one had a very short lifespan
um sorry really quick and i know and
then i'm gonna let you go i know i have
to
um your lifespan you're like is getting
shorter and shorter as he's
sitting here i'm consuming all of your
life's man um i know you have to get to
this book because it answers
your next book which because it answers
a question i would like to know the
answer to
um but is there anything to
if you're genetically predisposed to be
bald at a young age
could that be something that benefits
you you might not know why
but it is auspicious to you or the
person that
is experiencing it because of how
everything else in your body is designed
how it evolved and how your family's
trauma and stuff
like how much of genetics do we want to
change
like is there anything you're always
like let's not mess with this because
this is
auspicious for this person they were
designed this way for a reason to react
to certain circumstances like we can't
make
white arctic foxes blue they
are white for a reason that help them
make them blue i know
but we should they would be more likely
to die
that is true that is true but they'd be
prettier
that's very true and then they'd be just
as important yeah then they would be
more likely to
be captured and put in a zoo and maybe
they live longer when they're in
conservation who knows
now you're thinking yes see i'm pro-zoo
all of a sudden did you see that
no but is there anything like like like
changing in our lifetime when i have
kids
my eggs are frozen and i'm about to
freeze embryos right so
and i would like to use your sperm if
that's okay i can't imagine that would
be weird at all
um but changing the eye color of a
kid so you've already had children right
now let's say you
go for another one in five years
you'll be able to tinker with the eye
color right of course
of course um technology is there would
you i mean you have beautiful blue eyes
this is like
hitler's dream of a palette never been
called that
these like blue eyes but if you knew
your kid was gonna have brown eyes and
you're like i know
based on science that kids with blue
eyes do better in life they get hired
faster they have more choice of their
spouse or their whatever their life is
easier
you know you have to do what would make
your kid have a head start
it's gatako all over again i mean it's
you're a kid so it already has a head
start but
uh so i i think that we should
fix humanity any way we can as long as
it's safe
and ethical i think changing the color
of eyes right now
it's not safe enough and there's not a
good enough reason but i know it's an
example but if we change the color right
let me ask you
does are blue eyes more susceptible to
damaging uv rays so
you could be putting actually making
their
experience more dangerous by giving them
this aesthetic change
if blue eyes mean more eye cancer or
whatever
exactly right so that's why i wouldn't
do that but if i could protect them
against cancer by putting an extra few
copies of what's called the p53 gene
i would do that especially if it was
perfectly safe and only cost me ten
dollars would you tell them
yes that's that's yes of course but but
but is there anything to
doing it but not because if i know that
oh i'm 10 years old my dad is
david sinclair and he re-jiggered my dna
so i never need cancer
all right now i'm just gonna like drink
soda all day because i'm never gonna get
cancer i see a point
uh what if you don't tell them just be
like cancer runs in our family so not
only do you know they're not gonna get
it
but they're also gonna take care of
themselves and live longer yeah i think
there's a good one
my main advice is lie to children you
guys it's a very healthy i don't know
what this new thing is where you don't
abuse children psychologically it works
you know like i feel like there's gonna
have to be something down the line
that's gonna have to be intentionally a
little bit duplicitous
in order to reap the benefit and not
have
a benefit backfire well they might be
stigmatized if
they're known as the genetically
modified babies but i think eventually
most children if not all will be i know
that's controversial
but look at the world we're building
we're suffering
so anything that alleviates suffering
this is what i do
is there anything and then i'm letting
you guys wear uh is there anything that
like you see coming that could be a
major curve well minus like a meteor
hitting
just something of like this longevity
you know we're going to be able to live
to 200 years if everything keeps going
according to plan
unless the ozone layer collapse or
unless the acid rain comes or unless
you know a country builds this this atom
bomb
and we all you know what i'm saying or
unless there's a mercury spill
in the ocean and all of a sudden the
fish that we were going to rely on for
all this health is now all of a sudden
poisonous like is there anything that's
like
you look and you're like that happens
it's really going to throw a monkey
wrench into things
lots lots as i put in this book
pandemics are bad we could have a big
one um
this came out what six months before
yeah get ready for it i remember reading
and being like oh here we go the
pandemic chapter who's gonna worry about
of course
scientists just sit around worry about
these things that are never going to
happen
yeah sorry about that insane uh i
not in our lifetime probably but hitting
getting hit by an asteroid is not going
to be fun
that'll wipe us out probably but we can
we can engineer our way out of that too
so i think we can solve everything
we'll wipe out humanity when we don't
have any light for
10 years that's what it is do you know
about the seed bank
yeah have you been there
do you want to go let's go on a like a
fun
trip the global seed vault
in norway i think it's in norway this is
what it looks like and it has
every seed from every uh plant
ever in here so that if we do have
uh whatever an atomic bomb or some sort
of like major destruction in the world
this will still we need robots to go
we'll get lex to build us a robot
to go in and get the sea plants yes with
no light
but then but then the robots will say
but i don't need plants so why am i
doing this
look at this the fact that we've thought
ahead this far really makes me think
scientists know something we don't in
terms of imminent destruction
because why would all these people spend
so much money taking every seed putting
them in a vault
a thousand feet down in the thing if
something bad wasn't for sure gonna
happen well it's for sure gonna happen
it's happened many times before it's
just not gonna happen soon i don't think
but that building looks like something
out of star wars that's what they were
trying to do
and they have every single seed on the
inside
like this makes me feel very comfortable
for the future but also very worried for
the future because it makes me think
that
scientists you guys know something that
a lot of us do not know
and just aren't telling us because it
would cause mass panic
well i told you one thing but the
asteroid's gonna come
we just need to knock it out are we
gonna have technology to be able to
reroute it
for sure by the time we've got thousands
if not tens of thousands of years to get
ready
okay got it but what if we live that
long you're gonna make us live so long
that what if we all die by asteroids
this is the fate you want for us that we
live so long that we just get hit by an
asteroid i would like to die before then
please
sure that's my grand plan thank you and
um okay last question i'm letting you go
thought on
sen senescence therapy therapies to turn
on zombie cells back to healthy
functioning cells
yep that means that's a sandra bullet
question wow girl you're on she's on the
next level though she knows
she's just too small okay it's a good
question okay uh so senescent cells
accumulate in your body my skin probably
full of them
being an australian they cause havoc
they cause cancer they
cause a lot of inflammation and if you
get rid of them and you're a mouse they
live longer and in humans they get
healthier
metabolically so it's great to get rid
of them
there are a couple of ways of doing that
there are molecules called synalytics
there's
a couple of molecules i keep saying
molecules is that
chemicals supplements from plants one
called
physin one called quercetin these are
from
strawberries and onions that have been
found to kill these senescent cells or
at least make them less
aggressive and so that's one way to
heal these strawberries and onions no
good luck eating ten thousand
oh okay you could never get from them
the amount you need okay
no it's like trying to drink enough red
wine okay to get the antioxidants
well the resveratrol from red wine you
need to drink 200 glasses a day to get
the same amount that i'm
eating that's so funny which i mean
don't recommend i know a couple people
that probably do
yeah right doesn't make you live longer
but there's a new way that we have
discovered
well my graduate student's going to kill
me for saying this but we're excited
about the possibility
let's just say of instead of killing off
those senescent cells and if they're in
your brain you don't necessarily want to
kill them you just want to make them
healthy again
we are trying and promising results in
reprogramming those cells
to be normal again because they're not
messed up so much as people thought
it's just their epi genome is messed up
which we can now reprogram
and make normal again the way we
restored eyesight in those old mice
uh earlier this year and
so this would be instead of like like
the example i'm thinking of is like
chemotherapy where it's in order to kill
the cancer cell you also kill a bunch of
healthy cells too this would be just
targeting the one unhealthy cell
instead of trying to kill it and maybe
killing good ones and
the you just reprogram and make it good
right but you make it bored again
here's the other good thing is that you
can reprogram we think a senescent cell
to be normal
but if you reprogram a normal cell it
also gets younger
that's what we just published so we've
found a way to reboot yourself
how will how where is this available in
my lab do you want to come
yes i just shoot you up with a virus
then i'd have to get on a plane and then
i'd be bombarded with uv rays so it
would cancel out the whole point
last thing your thought on exosome
and stem cell therapies okay
so exosomes are little membrane things
that float in your blood that are very
small that have only just
in the last 10 years become well known
there's some really good therapies drugs
that are in development it's huge
so that there's there's nothing wrong
with exosomes other than
we don't know if they extend lifespan
but it's a huge
real field and there may be nobel prizes
awarded for it
i had i want to say five or six years
ago
a a friend of mine who is um the
daughter of a famous
comedian from the 70s who has like just
a lot of access
to fancy things and doctors he's aging
and trying all sorts of experimental
stuff i can tell you who it is
off the pot um but uh
she said i have this stem cell person
coming into town
he comes and he does like racehorses
which by the way we hate
we don't support racehorse sing any of
that shit it's it's awful
but um does expensive animals does
people
goes to the middle east like and i got
it it was a stem cell drip
okay was that real or was that a scam it
depends on the stem cell
and the doctor that there are some
really good stem cell therapies
for the knee uh-huh the problem with
stem cells
oh now you're thinking i'm gonna call
the doctor you're thinking
the things that make you decide
someone's legitimate or not if you have
no understanding of what credentials
mean i'm just like
i don't know i mean yeah i guess he did
have like some
purple on the back of his neck from
dying his hair like if he can't dye his
hair right he's probably not a good doc
the things that i would decide a good
doc constitute a good doctor
are just so ridiculous anyway i'm like
yeah he had a little leather bag and a
monocle
he must have been a real doctor she's
like
well it's pretty easy for me to know if
somebody knows what they're talking
about
because there's a lot of like like
people going over the border to mexico
to do these stem cell therapies and
and the celebrities that told me they
were doing and i was like well you don't
look that great so i'm not going to do
it but
you know in terms of like injuries i
shattered my shoulder
should i be putting stem cells in my
shoulder
well i'm not a doctor i'm not gonna say
you should do anything can you tell
doctors what to do
i advise doctors what would you advise
my shoulder doctor to do
with my shoulder uh get a good doctor
who knows what they're doing
um i know some knees that have been very
well repaired by
uh-huh stem cells the problem with stem
cells though is that they don't last
very long they don't go where they're
supposed to go
so our approach of reprogramming and
rejuvenating the cells that are already
there making them young
i think ultimately will be a better
approach but is the
um and i wonder if this is a problem in
australia
is this sort of hold up with stem cells
that
where we get stem cells a lot of people
constitute as human life
and that's the problem it's not
politicized that way
it used to be but now it's fine we can
make stem cells out of anything i could
take your got it
like takes a swab give me some of your
hair your skin
and i can if i had the time and money i
could clone you
mm-hmm um but we can also build we
already did that with the robot you saw
her it didn't go so well
no she's not in good shape
but we can do a lot with you i look at
that bitch every day and i'm like
i used to look like that so we could
grow a mini
whitney brain which we do in the lab
they're not whitney's but we could do
that we grow little organoids
we can grow skin and we could
make stem cells and put them back into
you are we going to be cloning humans at
some point or there's going to be laws
against
that i think there are laws against it
um somebody in china did that and it
wasn't
um no it was korea they claimed it but
do we even know what's going on
there's also like you know as i heard
you talking about this on i think it was
rogan about
you know government we don't know what
other countries are working on
so there's not like a universal global
like okay
even though we're from different
countries and we have different values
we're all the best science let's all
scientists log in the room and just
compare notes or is it still a very
furtive
like we don't want to share things
because then they could take it and do
something
well it's changed in the last few years
we scientists used to
talk all the time didn't matter
nationality but that's changed
uh it's been become political and even
today i got a letter
saying be careful where you teach um in
the world
so it's a rough time for scientists
actually it's not as collegial as it
used to be
we have to watch out um sharing ideas
there's a lot of suspicion especially
towards the east
okay but how do we know there's not
stuff they're working on over there i
mean the crisper baby that was
that was just what was made public like
is there anything
because i like to worry about things i
cannot control or fix at any point it's
like sort of my brand
um like do we need to worry that
that people are cloning each other um
i don't i think you've got bigger things
to worry about yeah i mean we should
worry about climate change at this point
it's doable it's really dope you can but
if we provide people
we might solve climate change in two
weeks if we're selectively cloning
brilliant people that could be the
solution don't clone everyone don't
clone the weirdos that are annoying
don't clone the people that shouldn't
even be around
there shouldn't be one of them much less
two of them but like is there any
case of like cloning you so that you can
be in five places at once
i've thought about it because i've got
too much to do i think one is enough
but it's only doable it could be being
done who knows like is that the fix of
how to save the world that it's not that
we're like
have one person trying to solve one
thing alone what if you had five of you
in your lab
maybe one day that'll happen i mean they
probably all wouldn't get along as my
guess but
that is for sure but um cloning dogs is
pretty easy
a friend of mine here in l.a his dog was
dead and they took some blood from him
and made three more not a fan uh
because the and look i'm also a person
that is so
attached to my dogs if i almost lost one
of my dogs a year ago
and there was i was googling it i was
you know when i'm
in a time of pain that seems like the
only solution i got to clone this dog
but when i found out the way that
they're born it's like via caesarean and
the mother usually dies and a lot of
other pups die
for the three good ones there's like it
just feel i'm big on just there's
5 000 dogs at the rescue right now that
are gonna be put down tonight
go get one of those because you'll learn
something about yourself taking in a dog
that you're gonna have to be patient
with and train like like to me you're
losing the experience of the medicine of
a dog
if you're just cloning one that you
already have that
is fitting to the person you were 10
years ago when you got the dog
like there's a dog that needs you and
you need a dog that's out there
that's going to teach you something what
about if your partner dies
should you bring them back not if i
killed them
or i guess i don't know if if i knew i
could bring my partner back to life i'd
kill them every morning
i'm just like who's that text from boom
once we can bring him back i'm just
sorry it was in the heat of the moment
i'm too worried about what i would do if
i knew i could
bring him back to life at any moment i
think that once there's kids in the
picture it's a different thing and
there's also something about
the way someone dies like if someone
drinks themselves to death
do we bring that person back to life
they don't want to live or they're not
they're not strong enough or whatever it
is
as someone that has a lot of family
members that died of cirrhosis but if
someone dies with some freak accident
that they didn't deserve and they died
too
young like is there ever going to have
to be a
you don't deserve to be brought back to
life and you
do deserve to be right like who would
ever even decide that but you said
that addiction is a disease and we
shouldn't vilify these people
so it's not their fault that's right i
agree with you but if someone
uh has three dui's and kills a
a school of children on a school bus
because they were drinking and driving
and harming other people constantly yes
i believe um as someone that subscribes
to 12-step programs and
emdr and hypnosis and all of the
addiction treatments that i know about
that i believe work
very well if you have the warrior spirit
there's some people
that just cannot do it for whatever
reason maybe because their
their addiction the addiction behind the
addiction is actually an eating disorder
or is trauma from childhood a lot of
people that have
eating disorders and plastic surgery
addictions have been molested as
children like but give people a second
chance
to live if they don't i totally are oh
interesting
we all deserve a second chance um i
agree that's
those might actually be the people
you're convincing me that
should be brought back to life first
because it's like you
you were dealt a shitty hand right now
you should get a fresh start
but if someone's like i don't want to go
through this again i'm just gonna
fucking get hooked on drugs and have to
live in that crowd like i don't want
this stop bringing me back to life
i don't want to live you know because
there are some people that when
when i lose someone in my life to
addiction whether they're still alive in
an active addiction and i kind of have
to just
um let go and detach with love because i
know that they're just
sort of a robot being puppeteered by
this
dopamine this beast inside them and i
can't take their behavior personally and
i can't
get hurt by them because they're just
ultimately hurting themselves and
their addiction has told them they're
going to die without this thing yeah
because i do believe that
that addiction is you know it's
everyone's problem if one person in your
family has an addiction
everyone in the family suffers people
want to go well the addict this you're
getting a disease
a mental disease in reaction to these
people so it's just as important to you
than it is to the person who's in active
addiction doing
the ostensibly illegal thing you're also
getting all these alcoholic behaviors
that are socially acceptable which is
like
you know love addiction food addiction
being in bad relationships perfectionism
addiction whatever it is
self-righteous indignation addiction the
kind of people that go on twitter enough
to be like
you guys are all wrong probably had a
active addict in their childhood they
couldn't control or that they developed
their personality in reaction to that
person if
i'm so perfect yet compared to the
person that was doing meth every day
you're still an
asshole you just developed your identity
in comparison so that's why you think
you're such a saint because the bar is
so low like you got to look at yourself
too
and how you're repeating these patterns
and becoming
the perpetrator that you were once a
victim of
you're now becoming just as toxic as
that person and that person has an
excuse as we say in al-anon which is
you know al-anon is you know uh aca
adult children of alcoholics when you
grew up in the
alcoholic column and you were born
addicted to drama or
chaos is normal to you and you have this
you know arrogance of well i'm not an
addict well i don't drink they're the
ones that drink they're the ones that
don't have their shit together they're
the ones that you know wake up at noon
and drink
i'm the one that's up in in getting into
a good school and doing all my homework
and then you go into
you know uh uh double winners meetings
have been very educational for me ones
that are
both al-anons that are family members if
you love an alcoholic
and again we define alcoholism not you
know
for alcoholism to be present alcohol
doesn't have to be present people i
never saw my parents drink that doesn't
mean they didn't have alcoholic
tendencies that doesn't mean they
weren't raging
they weren't leaving in the middle of
night to go get a prostitute they
weren't having multiple affairs they
weren't obsessing over cleaning the
house and cooking and everything being
perfect and
scrapbooking and decorating and whatever
there's many addiction shows itself in
many different ways
and um or looking at crazy shit on the
internet or
checking out teenage girls when they
walked by who we just we don't know
um but when you go into allen on rooms
it's all these people that just kind of
think they're perfect because
you know they didn't pick up that drink
or they're not you know they can have
one glass of wine and put it down
but then you into aaa meetings and you
see people be like well i was
i was drunk and i was texting and
driving and i that was my rock bottom
and then
i was using cocaine and my girlfriend
left me and i climbed over her wall
and broke into her house and then i'm
saying they're like i've done all this
shit
sober i have no excuse for my behavior i
just did this on the internal drug
cabinet alone
like you know if you're drinking at
least you have an excuse for your crazy
shitty behavior i just that's just my
personality i just thought that was a
good idea
when i had no alcohol in my body
[Music]
and your point is my point is i'm never
letting you leave this room
because i'm addicted to try getting
between an addict and their addiction
yeah and this is like this book is my
addiction you're my addiction this
this science is my addiction it gives me
hope i think comedians or or anyone
that's just thoughtful
and trying to vibrate on a conscious
frequency
is thinking about death and is living in
in fear and is trying to figure out what
our purpose is here and
there's a lot of ah what's the point i'm
38 i'm never gonna find the guy
there's a lot of like defeatist
philosophies that we have that are
really destructive because i think
we are resigned to not living that long
and i this you know on a bigger picture
giving hope of like
i don't need to give up now i can still
have a kid i'm 38 like
the idea of being in your 30s and 40s
not being the end of your life and being
like no this is when i'm at my smartest
i'm my most my 20s was a wash i mean i
was completely unconscious
like you know when people like i wish i
was in my 20s again i do not
i was the worst version of myself and i
was like i now i can actually be a
parent i can actually be a good partner
i can actually be a good podcast host
but i'm running out of time so
the tragic sort of shakespearean like
irony of that exactly so wisdom takes a
long time i'm still trying to figure out
life i'm in my 50s by the way 50s are
great
as long as you're healthy that's when
i'm going to be i feel like my smartest
and funniest and best and i
hope that i'm like able to go do 50
cities a year and like
share that with people yeah great we're
on
on the same page on that and and we
should be able to look forward to our
80s to be like that
one day why not and we'll just keep
getting smarter and
wiser and especially the existential
dread
of the our bodies are sexist people like
workplaces are sexist and people are
sexist in hollywood
biology's sexist like the thing that's
holding women back from having
everything they want
it's not producers necessarily it's our
bodies
they just start rotting the second you
get into your 20s you know so you know
for me i try to take the blame off of
people being like they're sending me mom
roles and
now that i'm my late 30s people don't
think i'm young whatever
my body is doing it my body's the
problem you know
and i have eggs on ice and even the
psychological
weight that was lifted off me when i
froze my eggs whether those are gonna be
viable or not whether they're gonna take
if i do ivf or whether i even use them
at all or like give them to a gay couple
or whatever
um or like give them as a giveaway on
our youtube channel who cares whatever
it is
or sell them on ebay just knowing that
i had an extra five years i can't stress
i don't have to tell you this because
this is what you've done carol
i can't tell you the amount i never
would have started a podcast i never
would be with
a healthy person i'd still be in a toxic
relationship with someone that was
really bad for me because i was like
well i can't get out of this i'm 35. i'm
gonna have to meet a new person and i'm
i'm just gonna have to settle for this
the amount of toxic decisions
that i was making in resigning myself to
and surrendering to
because i didn't think i had enough time
left isn't it freedom
that it's freedom to to change careers
to change partners if you need to
it's great i think the amount of people
bringing children into bad relationships
will go down which is then going to make
healthier
kids and help smarter people in general
because this fear of
well if i don't procreate right now i'm
never going to be able to so i'm going
to procreate with the wrong person that
i don't want to be with and i'm going to
show this kid all this negative toxic
shit and they're going to see resentment
and this is the bar they're going to
have for themselves
so they're going to repeat the cycle
it's like to me like the bigger
way to break these cycles
that age us emotionally that's brilliant
it's really true i mean when we're in
our 20s i had kids
early 30s i still didn't know how to
write a check
or you know pay for a mortgage and now
here i am raising kids that's ridiculous
i think you're right people our age
should be the ones raising kids
yeah no offense to everyone who's young
but you do get better at it
sure sure and there's there's there's
you know on the same token i'm going to
say adversity is good for kids and if
you're 22 and you've got a kid you have
no idea what you're doing that kid's
probably gonna grow up to be really
resilient and you were a good parent by
accident to them you know like for me i
look at all the mistakes my parents made
and i'm finally at the point where i go
oh my god they built but they gave me
super powers
that time they ignored me and dropped me
off at the wrong school and forgot about
me at school
it made me funny it made me strong you
know like i now see
all of those failures as what made me
resilient so
if you're 22 and you know you have no
idea what you're doing you're probably
gonna
build a scientist or a great artist or
something totally by accident for sure
and and one of the reasons people
still say don't have babies later in
life is because oh you'll be 70 by the
time they're in high school
but when you're 70 you can still be as
fit as a 30 year old why not
and high school might start at 10 by
then
if we genetically modify them to be
smarter hmm
do you have any questions for me
i'm totally where do i donate my sperm i
have to can i tell you i
i mean i did float this by lex freeman
where i was like look
i this does not have to be sexual there
is something to be said for people that
are like
okay we don't have to be in a
relationship we're all adults here but
like
we should just freeze embryos we can put
it in a surrogate
we'll sign something i don't think you
should only have kids with people
that you love because sometimes the most
brilliant people
are deeply unlovable and annoying and
impossible
and it's like but it's like this would
be a fa this child would do something
great but we should not date or be
together lots of people have kids with
people they don't love
it's called in many cases marriage yeah
but is there something to be said for
for
this is a kind of genetic engineering
that's just not under microscope the
idea of being like
okay you you and i should have a kid we
should not date
we'll fuck up the kid if we're married
because if they see this dysfunction
they it'll undo the whole point of
making this amazing kid
well co-parent there's nothing sexual
you go get married to whatever
weird fetish you're into and uh
i'll do whatever i'm doing but we'll
have this kid together because it's
going to do something cool
can you imagine what this kid would do
i'm imagining it yes
okay well yes i actually agree with that
i mean not us two but in general yeah
kids can be loved just as much by
co-parenting and there's something to be
said for being like commitment's not my
strong suit maybe it's because i just
haven't
i'm scared of it whatever it is i
associate it with i have bad
associations with it from my childhood i
need to do more therapy but
i do think i should have kids with a
couple people
that i don't date you know there's
there's times i'm like we're not good
together but our
dna would be
this is this is in our company right we
need to be the match right you you know
how whitney knows match.com yeah she
worked with match for five years
match.com oh my goodness yes so how
about that genetics
genetic compatibility you don't have to
be in a relationship why not
yes i swear is that i mean you can
change your genetics obviously but it's
like the idea of
like moving forward if you have the
perfect man but you hate his eye color
that can be fixed you know what i mean
it's like what are the things you know i
have this whole thing on red flags on
the podcast what are red flags like
moving forward certain red flags are not
going to be read anymore because you're
going to be able to
change them the fiction book last thing
i'm going to say super sad true love
story by gary steingart
is a dystopian satire about
dating in the future this was written
like 10 years ago and it's astounding
how sort of on the nose he has been
he's this brilliant satirical novelist
he wrote russian not russian debutants
handbook or i think he did
um lake success he's just so brilliant
and we were working on making
the tv show version of it black mirror
kind of did a couple of the things we
were playing around with but it is sort
of about how do you date
when all of your mistakes are
essentially available to the other
person
at any moment all of your weaknesses
because so much of dating
is about pretending it's right it's it's
like i'm gonna act like i'm the person
you want i'm gonna hide all the bad
things
and i'm gonna only present the good
things and con you basically
but in the future if i'm gonna be able
to know your blood pressure your credit
score
your blood type and your
propensity to get cancer like yeah am i
not even going to give you the first
three months
that's when you drop it on them when
someone's already in love with you and
you're like and i have a heart defect
you're like fuck
now i love you even more you have a
broken heart whereas if i knew that to
begin with i'd be like
it's irresponsible for me to date you
because then i would be doing this to my
child knowingly
right imagine that i i'm i'm not going
to die at 50
right or or i could die next week you
could know that
ahead of time my biological age is
actually really gonna love this
technology
he's gonna die next week let's get
married now
guys are gonna have a problem with it
guys are gonna be like i don't want them
knowing i'm gonna die
they're trying to gold dig me even
though all i do is show off my gold
all i do is drive bentleys and mercedes
and show my watches on instagram but why
why are women so shallow why are they
trying to gold dig me you want it
you want it and you love it you can put
your death date on your t-shirt
if you want
[Music]
but but but if i know my death date is
september 10th 2050
aren't i gonna go i'm running out of
time so i'm gonna act even healthier and
that's gonna change the date
yes that's the reason for this company
to basically scare the shit out of
someone
into living longer by telling them
they're gonna live less long
well waking people up to the fact that
they will die but
there are things you can do you can't
delude yourself anymore
well it's not supposed to be scary it's
empowering you don't drive a car without
a dashboard why do we do that for our
health fascinating
well i have to let you go i thought you
weren't gonna let me go
i don't want to i have no interest this
is why i want to break your legs so
badly so that i can keep you here
forever have you ever seen the movie
boxing helena
it's a movie where this uh crazy surgeon
is so madly in love with this woman that
he
saws off her arm and arms and legs and
just lifts so she can't go anywhere
and lives with her torso i think it's
very romantic
uh kim basinger famously was attached to
it and then backed out
and then they sued her like there's like
a big hollywood saga around the movie
but i can't imagine why she backed out
of that
genius idea but yeah i do often
fantasize about
handicapping people i'm obsessed with
and keeping them in my home like on a
mantle
i should have known that before no one
told me
but we're gonna do your age how about
that we'll do a cheek swab
right now we can take one sure why don't
i come
where when do you go back to boston
don't they want me to speak at harvard
don't they want me to speak at your lab
i'd be honest please come if you guys
can afford my fee
i'll make it we have a sign up if you
want to sign up okay to get this test
are you doing with a couple people in
hollywood some of these
these riff-raff that you hate some of
these losers that you hang out with in
hollywood are you gonna do with them too
uh yes i won't say who they are
okay um but they're at the top of the
sign up list already okay
it's like getting a tesla you gotta know
you
well you know we're open to testing
eventually millions of people but we we
want to
have people are really into this sign up
now for the early
version so we have a place to sign up
all right
i'm in thank you
yeah whitney's losing her mind over
there
um do you wanna can i say the place to
sign up is that
yes please say everything oh so we've
we've set up a place where people can
sign up
to get this test when when it's done
okay
okay and let's go to the website now
okay it's there it's forever.net
no it's called doctorsinclair.com with
spelling doctor
oh dot the whole word d-o-c-t-e-o-r
sinclair dot com yeah i end these very
awkwardly
because there's no way to really do
justice to being able to hear you talk
this long so i'm just gonna let it
literally and figuratively speak for
itself
do you have a good time yes are you mad
about what i don't know
i'm just so fascinated with how
you know they say like god doesn't give
with two hands like the fact that there
is a forward-facing scientist that is so
eloquent and charming and like it's just
such a and still employed
gift right because not uh
you know there was that show scorpion
that was on cbs for a while it was about
this company that would have like
babysitters for super smart geniuses
that didn't have like social graces and
who couldn't like
pitch to investors and talk to doctors
because they were just too nerdy
i'm just saying you don't need that keep
saying you don't need someone to
translate what you're saying
you're able to do it in a way that makes
me feel like i actually understand what
you're saying and the chances are
don't even thank you like i feel like in
my day
i feel like i was able to have a
conversation with you but i'm sure i was
just beyond out class like that's such a
gift
thank you you're welcome and i mean that
sincerely i'm
i've been a fan for a long time agree
smart you're a smart man they don't just
give you a phd if you're not a fan of me
that's the final question on the exam
[Laughter]
well if someone had said 15 years ago
that i'd be here i
wouldn't have believed it so serendipity
is real ditto
i get to like have people i'm obsessed
with in my house like it's just why it's
wild
it's not a bad job if you can get it if
i can get you into my house
we can live for 200 years the most
impossible thing has happened already so
i'm i'm open to anything
i'm sold um okay so thank you david
sinclair
dr sinclair.com lifespan if you don't
have it
you hate yourself like i don't even know
what kind of person you are if you don't
have this yet
um and the second book you're working on
it yes but you'll be back when it comes
out
if not sooner you said it on camera
you said it on camera um okay i love you
guys thank you what a joy what an
honor what a pleasure i hope you enjoyed
my
silk shirt that i wore for you and that
i spilled all over
is being nervous and frazzled and don't
ride elephants
per usual thanks guys
four four four
you